مطار جديد ومتحمسين وفرحانين الناس بعدين
تيجي الايه يعني العام الماضي اللي صار في
في رمضان كان كارثه كان شيء مخيب صراحه
صادم
ويخدش همم شرف وجوده خدمتها لضيف الرحمن
الحمد لله احنا نفتخر فيه لسنوات ثم انت
تيجي هذه المحطه كده الاخيره وتحوس الدنيا
صراحه المؤلمه جدا مؤلمه اكثر لانه كنا
نضل انه المشكله الوحيده في مطار جده هي
المطار نفسه فبوني مطار بهذا السعر بهذه
الضخامه ودي افهم مش مشكله مطار جده اللي
حصل في رمضان كان يعني بالنسبه
ومحرج
وكان فعلا يعني جميعا اتحمل مسؤوليه لكن
لابد في اسباب مش الاسباب
[موسيقى]
استضيف قاعده التحول وقاده الاعمال وقاده
الراي وسولف معهم على المستجدات ومستندات
رؤيه السعوديه 20 30 اليوم هو معالي
الاستاذ عبد العزيز الدعيلج رئيس الهيئه
العامه للطيران المدني موضوع يشتغل ويهم
الكثيرين من عده زوايا في حلقه اليوم
طويله لان نحاول نغطي اغلب اذا ما كان كل
الملفات اللي تم المشاهدين ابتدينا الحلقه
بملخص سريع لرحله الطيران المدني من عام
1945 الى اليوم ايش المراحل اللي مر فيها
هذا القطاع وبعدين تكلمنا على المشهد
اليوم همم الهيئه شركه المطارات وزاره
النقل الخطوط الناقله او شرحنا بشكل ميسر
الدوار كل همم جهه وبعدين انتقلنا الى
حكايه التحول واللي هي التحول من مشهد من
وجهه نظري انا مخيب في قطاع الطيران على
كافه المستويات همم الى استراتيجيه
للطيران تطمح انها تعالج كثير من هذه
التحديات فتحدثني عن استراتيجيه هذه وش
اهم المستهتافاتها كيف بنحقق 330 مليون
مسافر واحنا اليوم 100 مليون مسافر ايش
المطرين اللي مسؤولين عن تحقيق ثلثين هذا
المستهدف اا وبعدين دخلنا في موضوع
الخطوط الطيران اللي موجوده وش الفرق بين
الخطوط مكتمله الخدمات والخطوط الاقتصاديه
همم كم عدد الخطوط تكون موجوده في اقتصاد
وبلد بحجم السعوديه همم موضوع اسعار
تذاكر الطيران ومشاكلها موضوع صار ثلاثه
واربعه في مدينه الرياض اللي في فتحت بشكل
اقل بكثير من توقعت الناس ايش الكواليس
وايش القصه في همم هذه الصاله مطار جده
الماسات اللي ما احد كان يرضاها ولا
يقبلها اللي صارت في رمضان العام الماضي
مع ضيوف الرحمن مع المعتمرين مع المسافرين
في مطار جده مش قصه هذيك المشكله ايش الان
همم
المعالج لها وايش القادم في مطار جده
سكان مدينه الرياض لحظه مشكله في موضوع
الرحلات المباشره من مدينه الرياض صارت
قليله كل رحلات صارت عن طريق جده
ايش المشكله هنا وايش علاقه هذا الشيء
بوجود مطارين رئيسيه تكلمنا شويه عن مطار
الملك سلمان عن الجديد عن الخطوط الطيران
الجديده تكلمني عن موضوع المنطقه الشرقيه
ونقص الخدمات في الطيران اللي قاعد يصير
على الرجل على مجموعه من المطارات في
المملكه واخذنا المستجدات انشائها مثل
المطار ابها مطار القنفذه همم ومطارات
اخرى مطار جيزان وكذلك مطارات اخرى على
مستوى المملكه اتكلمنا على الكفاءات تاهيل
وتدريب همم
السعوديين تكلمنا على همم الخدمات الرقميه
عموما في الهيئه اللي تعتبر متدنيه
ومتراجعه جدا وهذي كانت مجموعه همم من ضمن
اسئلتكم اللي كانت هنا فيها كعادتكم في كل
حلقه فا- همم اترككم على الحوار حياك الله
ابو عبد الله شرفتنا ونور سلام الله يحييك
وسعيد بوجودك وشكرا على كريم الصداقه الله
يحييك احنا الاسعد بسالت ابو عبد الله ناس
يعملون معك وناس من اسرتك عن عن الاشياء
الغير المعلنه
ولقيت فيه قاسم مشترك كرروها الطرفين انه
ابو عبد الله دقيق جدا في التفاصيل الى حد
البرفكشن يقول انه لو تغير مكان القلم في
مكتبه حيضايق وحيرجع المكانه فالسؤال هل
الشخص البرفكشن او الكمالي يقدر ينجز
واللي بيصير غارق في التفاصيل
والله هذا السؤال صراحه هذه شكرا على
التفاصيل اللي دخلت فيها وهمم
بالعكس لان هذا الحقيقه طبعا هذه يمكن صفه
تعلمتها من وادي الله يغفر لها يعني هو
يعني الناس الدقيقتين جدا اللي دائما يبحث
عنك
دائما
سرعه الانجاز لانه
اتذكر في همم لما بدات دوت كوم
واللي انتظروا لكمال ال 100% او 95% امرهم
ما بداوا او تعداهم السوق وطلعت افكارها
بدون شكل يعني الموضوع انك تكون يعني هي
عمليه كيف توازن بين انك يمكن الواحد طبعا
العمر شويه يكون اكثر بعد يعني حرص دقه
لكن الانجاز مطلوب مطلوب وما في شك انه
يجب انه ما يكون على حساب يعني ما تكون
الدقه على حساب الجهاز بس هذه في النهايه
يعني
طبع تحديدا في الملف اللي انت اليوم ههه
الرئيس التنفيذ اللي همم الهيئه العامه
للطيران المدني همم وتقود هذا القطاع اللي
جدا جدا مهم وحيوي لكثيرين على مستوى ال-
ال- الافراد او حتى الاعمال او حتى
الاقتصاد همم فخلينا نبدا قبل ما ندخل في
الملفات الساخذه نبدا
ناخذ كده استعراض سريع رحله الطيران
المدني اللي اعتقد ابتدات 1948 في
السعوديه الى المرحله اللي احنا فيها
اليوم ونصف فيها المشهد بشكل مختصر طبعا
الطيران المدني في المملكه قصه وبدات في
عام 1945 ما وصلت اول طائره
الداخوته 3 الملك عبد العزيز
وبدات من بعدها تاسيس
مصلحه الطيران المدني وكانت في وقتها
تضمتها
الارصاد مصلحه الارصاد والخطوط السعوديه
يعني الخطوط السعوديه والارصاد والطياره
المدني كانت مصلحه واحده في عام 45 طبعا
اسمح لي قبل التحدث عن الخطوط
المملكه لانه يتكلم عن
المنظمه او ال- اتفاقيه شيكاغو يعني
شيكاغو اتفاق وهي اول اتفاقيه بين الدول
وقعت في ديسمبر سبعه ديسمبر 1944
في شركه 250 دوله ليه تنظيم
سنوات المنظمه الدوليه للطيران الدولي
وبعد ثلاث سنوات في ديسمبر برده سبعه همم
47 همم
بدات او انشئت منظمه الطيران المدني
الدولي تحت وكاله الاقتصاد والشؤون
الاقتصاديه والاجتماعيه في هيئه الامم
المتحده
همم وطبعا بعد تم المصادقه عليها في هذا
العام سبعه لذلك اصبح سبع نساء بار هو يوم
الطيران العالمي
وانضمت الدول اتباعا والمملكه انضمت في
عام 1962 فبراير 62 للمنظمه كعضو كامل
طبعا عوده على المملكه في 45 تم انشاء
المصلحه ب 53 1953 يعني وضع اول نظام او
نواه اول نظام الطيران المدني
وفي 1959
استقالته او خرجت الخطوط السعوديه استقلت
وبقت الارصاد مع الطيران المدني
في 62 كما ذكرت في فبراير انضمت المملكه
لكعضو كامل كتاب المصادقه على الانضمام
هذه المنظم الطيران المدني الدولي في في
مونتريال كم اصبح مقرها مونتريال بعد
اتفاقيه شيكاغو كان في همم تنافس من
مجموعه من الدول على استضافه المقر كانت
مونتريال وجنيف وباريس فازت فيها في وقت
الموت
في 66 1966 استقلت الارصاد واصبحت مصلحه
الارصاد طبعا البيع يمكن اضيفه لاحقا
عليها
وتحول اسم ال ال المصلحه الى مديريه اصبحت
مديريه الطيران الى عام 1977 تحولت من
مديريه الى رئاسه اصبحت رئاسه الطيران
المدني
واستمرت كرئاسه تابعه لوزاره الدفاع
الطيران الى عام 2004 صدر قرار مجلس
الوزراء بتحويلها الى هيئه هيئه الطيران
المدني هي العامه للطيران المدني لها يعني
صفه اعتباريه واستقلاليه ماليه واداريه
وكان من اهدافها طبعا العمل على اساس
التجاري وهذه انطلاقه الاولى
لتخصيص اعمال ال- القطاع الطيران في
المملكه اللي بدات في 2005 في تخصيصالات
الحج والعمره في مطار الملكه جده وبعدها
في 2011 2012 مطار الامير محمد بن عبد
العزيز في المدينه المنوره
يمكن من المحطات الحاسمه في الرحله هي
2016 لما اط رؤيا اصبحت انتم جزء من
منظومه الطيران المدني او منظومه عفوا
النقل همم
وهذه يمكن من اهم سمات يعني الهيكل اللي
صارت بعد الرؤيه انه صار في مفهوم منظومات
همم مش قيمه هذا مفهوم وايش الفرق وزاره
الدفاع واليوم تبع وزاره النقل وايش اللي
يفرق وطبعا يمكن في استراد بعد بعد ما صدر
القرار الوزاره لتحويل ال- ال-
الرئاسه الى هيئه مستقله في
2011 همم صدر امر ملكي فاصلها عن وزاره
الدفاع واصبحت مستقله في ذلك الوقت ترجع
مباشره
وفي 2016 زي ما تفضلت بعد البرامج الرؤيه
ااه انيط او عيد ارتباطها بوزاره النقل
واصبح وزير النقل هو رئيس مجلس الاداره
والهدف من هذا التحول هو زي ما اتفضلت انه
اليوم جميع برامج رؤيه تعمل تحت موضوعات
وهذا احد يعني اسرار نجاح النجاح اليوم
نمر فيها سواء على مستوى الرؤيه رؤيه 20
30 ببرامجها المختلفه او لما تنزل تحت على
مستوى همم منظومه النقل والخدمات
اللوجستيه او استراتيجيه الطيران الوطني
وما يتبعها من من جهات مختلفه
دائما شبهها بموضوع انه كان في يعني طول
السنه الماضيه كان في عمل يعني جيد لكن
كان ينقصه تناغم تنسيق تنسيق والترابط زي
التروس اللي كل الكرسي يعمل لحاله اليوم
بفضل الله بفضل الرؤيه العظيم بفضل همم
يعني رؤيه المهندسه الرؤيه ثم سيدي انه
اليوم جميع المنظومات تعمل بتناغم همم
سواء على مستوى برامج الرؤيه وعلى مستوى
منظومه النقل او على مستوى منظومه الطيران
لان احنا اليوم يمكن اتكلم لك لاحقا على
الجهات اللي اليوم نتناغم ونسق معها في
قطاع النقل الجوي بشكل عام في المملكه همم
برضه يعني لو مشينا شويه هنلاقي انه في
الخط الزمني حقكم بدات تنفصل المطارات على
الهيئه واسست شركه الطيران المدني القابضه
للاهل اسمها مطارات على منظن ومريته
بمرحله التحول المؤسسي ففي همم مطارات
تحولت الى الشركات
واضمن اكتمل هذا كله العام الماضي 2002
فاليوم مده نعرف ابو عبد الله قبل ما ندخل
فيه استراتيجيه الطيور المدينه
اللي في السعوديه بدنا نعرف اليوم مين هم
اللاعبين في هذا القطاع فاحنا نعرف
الوزاره يعرف الهيئه نعرف شركه نعرف خطوط
السعوديه هذول كلهم بالنسبه كثيرين
وشيء واحد فانا لما اروح واواجه مشكله في
المطار فلا ادعي على مين ههه اللي بنعرف
المشهد هذا
يعني من هم اللاعبين فيه واشترك اللاعب
شوفوا يعني انقطاع الطيران قطاع محقد
واطراف اللي تعمل فيه يعني كثيره جدا بس
خليني ارجع خطوه على موضوع التنظيم يعني
هو في عام
وزاره النقل والعامل تحت المنظومه وتسريع
عمليه التخسيس لتخصيص بدات لكنها ما كانت
تسير من الوتيره المطلوبه وتعثر في مراحل
كثير لانه
الاصول والمطارات والاراضي التابعه
المطارات والعقود والموظفين العمليه صراحه
يعني تحتاج وقت تصادر الامر سامي في شهر
اربعه 1438 اللي احنا نعتبر اليوم هو
خارطه الطريق
لاستراتيجيه الطيران
همم المدني الوطني في المملكه اللي وضع
مجموعه من الخطوات اللي ستنتهي المفروض
تنتهي قريبا بتخصيص الكامل للقطاع وفصل
اهم نقطه فيها هي يمكن عشان نجيب على
السؤال فصل الاعمال التنظيميه والاشرافيه
عن الاعمال التنفيذيه هيئه الطيران المدني
في السابق كانت يعني هي المنظم وهي
المشرفه وهي اللي تراقب الاداء وتبني
المطارات
وبتشغل المطارات وتصون المطارات فبالتالي
كان في تداخل كبير بين المهام والاشرافيه
والتنظيميه والرقميه والمهامه التشغيليه
فالامر السام الكريم يعني بالنسبه لنا هو
زي ما قلت الطريق 170 149 الصادق في شهر
اربعه 34 وضع خارج الطريق واضحه عملنا
عليها خطواتها وحده وحده يمكن باقي عندنا
الخطوه الاخيره في زي ما تفضلت في بدايه
همم في واحد واحد 22
استكملنا تحويل جميع المطارات والاصول
والعقود التجاريه والعقود التشغيل
والصيانه والموظفين الى شركه مطارات
القابضه وشركات التابعه سواءا بطولات
الرياض مطارات جدا مطرات الدمام ومطارات
التجمع الثاني وهذه لها قصه هل هي ليش
متجمع الثاني ليش مش عده التجمعات مختلفه
فهذا الناحيه فاليوم عندنا منظم
والجهه يعني رجليتر اللي هو الهيئه يفترض
انها تقوم بادوارها الاصيله حسب همم
تشريعات منظم الطيران المدني الدوليه
يعني بالتنظيم يعني بقول لك مثلا همم
اتفاقيه شيكاغو في اكثر من 40 بنده وفيها
19 ملعه
الملاحق هذه بتوعنا بالادوار الاصيله
للطيران المدني سواء تصاميم المطارات
تراخيص الطائرات تراخيص الطيارين الملاحه
الجويه امن الطيران التسهيلات الجويه
المعايير البيئه يعني فيها حوادث الطيران
لا سمح الله كل ملحق يعنى بموضوع معين في
تفاصيل كثيره وهذه اللي هي وهذا هو الدول
الاساسي وطبعا فوق هذا كله حمايه المسافر
وحقوق المسافر وهذا اليوم هو هذا دور
الاساسي اليوم الهيئه رقم واحد هو حمايه
حقوق المسافرين يعني وتوفير تجربه مريحه
وسلسه للمسافر هذا صراحه هدف الرسائل
المواطن السعودي والمقيم السعودي يستحق
اكثر مما هو اللي موجود
وبالتالي ما عاد نشوف مثلا المشهد كان
يصير سابقا لانه رئيس هيا ترى مدني هو
نفسه رئيس مجلس اداره الخطوط السعوديه
مثلا
احنا الشباب
رئيس مجلس اداره القطاع اللي هو يراقبه
وما في اليوم اليوم الحاله اللي عندنا هو
رئيس الطيران المدني هو يراس مجلس اداره
المنطقه
انه موضوع مؤقت الى ان نستكمل اجراءات
التخصيص والتحويل لكن بدون شك يعني هو
يفترض انه رئيس الطيران المدني اللي هو
صفه استقلاليه كامله عن جميع الانشطه التي
انا في الطائره المدنيه سواء ناقلات او
مطارات او مقدمه خدمات او اي جهه اخرى
تعمل في قطاع هذا الهيئه طيب الشركه الحين
همم نتحدث عن الشركه شويه ومش حجم الاصول
اللي تحتها بالضبط الحجم الاصول اللي تحت
الشركه يفوق 100 مليار 100 مليار
لانك انت وفي ازدياد لانك انت تتكلم عن
يعني جميع مطارات المملكه اليوم مطار جده
مطار الرياض في المطار عندنا عندنا اليوم
29 مطار ونتوقع ان احنا يعني تزيد يعني في
مطار البحر الاحمر الجديد القادم في مطار
اليوم خادم امانه في امانه يعني امانه
يعني
المؤكد المملكه قاره مسحتنا اكثر من
مليونين هم 100 كلم مربع فبالتالي طبيعه
العمل في قطاع الطيران في المملكه يختلف
عن كثير من دول المنطقه لذلك يعني في في
حال المقارنات سواء على مستوى الخدمات على
مستوى المطارات على مستوى
الشركات
دورها دورها هو همم انشاء المطارات تشغيل
المطارات
الاشراف على جميع الاعمال الى علاقه يعني
الهدف من الصراحه ان يكون عندنا ما يسمى
بالنشر شعبي
ممكن حتى ي- يعني يقوم يعني بدل ما نستعين
بدول الاخرى اليوم لتشغيل مطارات الهدف
انه يكون عندنا يعني مشغل وطني همم متمكن
على مستوى عالي لتشغيل مطاراتنا باعلى
كفاءه وباعلى المعايير وان شاء الله
مستقبل يساهم في تشغيل المطارات
فهذه المطارات القابضه تحتها مطارات
الرياض تحت الرياض وتحتها جده وتحتها اربع
شركات اليوم تقريبا اللي هي شركه موتورات
طبعا القابضه هي دورها الاستراتيجيات
والاستثمار والتخسيس وقت موضوع التخسيس
الموضوع يعني برضه مهم واحنا ماشيين فيه
الخطوات
والشركات القائم الاخرى اللي هي تطوير
المطارات زي مطار الملك خالد او مطار
الملك سلمان وهو القادم الان ومطار الملك
عبد العزيز وجده وطاهر الملك فهد في
الدمام
وتجمع الثاني للمطارات اللي هو يشمل بقيه
المطارات الاخرى اللي تم انتقائدها جميعا
في بدايه كثيره
سريع ثلاث مطارات كل وحده شركه مستقله
وبقيه مطارات انحطت الشركه واحده وايش
السبب
اسباب متعدده كان في عده خيارات هل احنا
نجيء للتجمعات مثلا الشماليه ونحطها شركه
والجنوبيه ونعملها شركه يعني يسمون
له علاقه بالنتورك بالشبكه الطيران وله
علاقه بالتكاليف اييه باسباب التكلفه
والوقت يعني بدل ما يكون عندك عده شركات
وكل شركه لها
مجلس اداره يعني راينا بعد الحقيقه
الدراسات مستفيده انه قد يكون في المرحله
الحاليه هذا هذا افضل مثال وممكن يتطور
الى نماذج اخرى في المستقبل
وفي يعني الخطوط خطوط الطيران هذه شو
علاقتها
بالهيئه وبالمطار او بشركه المطارات طيب
هي علاقه
كانت متداخل الان احنا طبعا نعمل على فصل
الادوار وضوح الامام يعني انت يجب ان تكون
لما لا سمح الله يصير عندك اشكاليه تعرف
من هو المسؤول وين حصل الخلل وشاشه سنك
والله يعني توجه الاتهامينه بس انت تعالج
الخلل يعني احنا مرينا خلال يعني الاعمال
الماضي بتحديات كبيره يعني العوده السريعه
للسفر بعد في بدايه رمضان كانت يعني همم
ما اقول مفاجاه بس كانت اكبر من قدره
المطارات
والناقلات والجهات العامله خدمات ارضيه
وغيرها همم تمويل على التعامل معها التوقف
اللي حصل في فتره الاولى همم بالكامل يعني
طلع على فكره
كثير من القطاعات الاقتصاديه تاثرت
بالكرونه بس بدون قطاع الطياره هو اكثر
قطاع تاثر اذا عندك 100 طائره على الارض
لمده سنه كامله يعني لك ان تتخيل حجم
الخسائر التي واجهتها الشركات ونعرف
عالميا انه عشرات بالمئات الشركات خرجت من
السوق ولولا يعني توفيق خلص امتحانات ثم
دعم القياده في خلال الازمه دعمه الناقلات
ودعمه نظام ساند دعم الموظفين يعني ومع
ذلك طبعا حصلت برامج ترشيد للتكاليف تخفيض
لبعض
الانشطه العمل اللي ما كانت يعني كان لا
يمكن انك تلقيها في ظل التوقف التام
فالعوده كانت تحتاج وقت وهذه من الاسباب
اللي يعني صراحه همم ادت الى همم حصل فيه
تكدس حصل في تاخير ولكن تم التعامل معه
معه لذلك انا بارجع اسمه بطل في بالي
افكار كثيره
المهم اليوم ان يكون في وضوح وفصل في
المهام وتحديد المسؤوليات واللي انا فهمته
انه عندنا الهيئه هي المنظمه المراقب
عندنا شركه مطارات هذه اصبحت اليوم هي
اللي تملك هذه المطارات وهي اللي تشغلها
وهي اللي بكره قد تبيع او تخصص بعض هذه
المطارات صحيح وعندنا خطوط الطيران هذا
اليوم ايضا مستقله مفصوله تماما وهي اللي
تقوم بتقديم الخدمه همم خدمه النقل الجوي
للمسافرين وعندك الله يسلمك ال- القطاعه
الاخرى يعني المنظومه كبيره طيران
القطاع الخدمات الارضيه جميع الخدمات اللي
تقدم في المطار يعني اللي اللي بوشباك
الطياره اللي ركب لك الجسر اللي يعمل
يعني تتزوج بالوقود اللي يعمل الحقائب
ومناوله الحقائب هذا من اهم الموظفين اللي
على الكاونترات الاستقبال التعامل مع
المسافرين الصيانه التموين همم كل الاعمال
هذه جهات العامله شركات يعني اللي عامل في
المطار جهات الامنيه اللي تعمل في المطار
وتامن والهم دور ضخم كبير في عمليه تسوون
التفتيش داخل المطار او الجمارك او
الحمايه المطارات يعني انت تتعامل اليوم
مع انا دائما افكر اقول لو انت تبغى تحجز
اليوم تفتح الابلكيشن وتعمل حجز
تتخيل كم جهه تتعامل معها من لحظه تعملك
الحج الى ان تقلع الطائره
يمكن 20 جهه تتعامل معها فبالتالي
والتفسير بين هذه الجهاد اي طرف يعني يحدث
قصور في دوره لاي سبب الاسباب يؤثر على
جميع فلذلك التنسيق وروح المهام وضوح
المسؤوليات هو من اهم الاولويات اللي نحن
بنعمل عليها واللي نامل فعلا اذا نجحنا
فيها ان شاء الله ستحسن بشكل كبير من
تجربه المسافر وهمم يعني
وتكون السفر متعه وليس معاناه
[موسيقى]
من تطور البناء الى اناقه التصميم ورفاه
الخدمات مع تميز الموقع حلول سكنيه مبتكره
ومستدامه مع شركه صفا للاستثمار المزيد في
وصف الحلقه
[موسيقى]
اخر سؤال في موضوع نحنا لسه محور حكايه
الجهاز قاعدين نحاول نفهم القطاع ونفهم
الهيئه اخر سؤال قبل ما انتقل الى حكايه
التحول اول ما دخلت موقعكم الرسمي اهداف
الهيئه تتذكر اول الهدف
اول هدف احد عندنا بالنسبه لنا اذا ما
تحدث هذا المشكله
ابو عبد الله عن تحسين تدريش اول هدف
لقيته سلاميه الموارد الماليه والعمل باسس
تجاريه تحقق الاستقلال المالي
فاذا كان هذا اول هدف
فيعني ما اظن هدف الجهات حكوميه هو تحقيق
المردود المالي رقم واحد عاده
تحسين التجربه على تطوير
احنا طبعا احد الاهداف اللي عندي ده ولك
هو على يعني اخر قائمه هو الاستدامه
الماليه وهذا المطلوب صحيح
العمله والسلام
السلام اليوم عندنا من اهم احنا القطاع
الطيران ما فيه يعني ما في لعب ما في
تجاوز ولا واحد في المليون على السلامه
بالتالي الاهداف الاصيله واللي هي حقوق
المسافرين تجربه بتحسين تجربه المسافر
السلامه
المعايير الالتزام بالوقت وهو الى اخره
وياتي بعدها موضوع
النمو النمو في ال في في القطاع تطوير
القطاع هذه كلها من الاهداف اليوم
تنميه الموارد الماليه وايش مصادر همم
داخل الهيئه وش ال ال نماذج او او موارد
الان يعني احد الموارد هي همم المشاركه
بنسب بسيطه يعني احنا نكون زي ما يقولون
همم
يكون عندنا ترى حتى النظام الملاحه حسب
منظم الطيران الدول هو مبني على همم
كاليف احنا نبغى يكون عندنا مصادر مستدامه
همم تكفي لانه الهيئه تقوم بادوارها
الاصيله وش هالمصادر هالعبور الطائرات في
اجواءنا انتم تاخذوا شركه الملح لاحد
شركات التابعه للهيئه لكنها فهذا مصدر
المصدر اهم مصدر عندنا اليوم هو مشاركه
المطارات في نسب من همم الاجور المطرات
وهذا تغطي حوالي 70% يفطر في رسوم على كل
تذكره الطيران ياخذها المطار
ناخذ منها جزء بسيط هذا ثاني في غيره
تصاريح التراخيص التي تصدر كل هذه تمثل
يعني هذا ال 30% الباقيه جميع انواع
التراخيص يعني تعرف اي طائره تعبر الاجواء
فيها رخصه الخامات الزمنيه رخصه التصاريح
للطائرات الجديده او الخطوط الجديده تدخل
المنطقه اي تصاريح همم
تعتبر جزء من الداخل الاضافي ولكن لا زالت
اقل من تكاليف اليوم
انتم عندكم
خلال ثلاث سنوات القادم بحيث ان يكون
عندنا توازن مالي همم يحقق الاستلام
الماليه للهيئه
ويضمن انها تقوم بادوارها بالشكل اللي
بحضرنا الثاني ابو عبد الله اللي هو حكايه
التحول هذا اهم محور في ال- في الحلقه هو
اللي بنشرح فيه يتغير في القطاع
الماضيه همم من وجهه نظري واعتقد كثير
يشاركوني الراي انه قطاع الطيران مخيب جدا
في السعوديه اقل من طموحاتنا على مستوى
مطارات لا تواكب همم تجربه الزائر ولا حتى
المواطن اللي يتنقل داخل المملكه ناقل
وطني انك مؤخرا في اجتهادات جيده قاعد
يحاول فيها بس انه بطبيعه الحال الجيران
سبقوه بمراحل وصار هم خيارا الاول سواء
كجود الطائرات او تعدد وجهات فالمشه جدا
جدا استثماريه ما هي جابه كل شركات
الطيران تحت فلشت الا الطيران الناس وهذا
احنا نحكي فيها بعد شوي فهذا المشهد لخصوا
همم يعني ولي العهد في مايو 2017 لما
السائل احنا غيرنا من في الطيران من وين
كان الغياب استراتيجيه ما عندنا
استراتيجيه كل احنا عندنا موكلات يعني
افضل بكثير من اي همم دوله ثانيه في
المنطقه في موضوع الاستراتيجيه سيتغير
المشي
فا اعتمدت الاستراتيجيه استراتيجيه
الطيران المدني فخلينا ننطلق من هذا
الاستراتيجيه ونقول
مش اهم ملامح الاستراتيجيه وايش التحديات
اللي افترض تعالج هذه الاستراتيجيه ممتاز
طبعا
فهم السؤال
المملكه اليوم قاره وفيها امكانيه
سواءا الموقع الجغرافي بين القارات الثلاث
التنوع الجغرافي التنوع الثقافي
من عسير الى تبوك الى البحر الاحمر الى
اليوم الى الشرقيه الى الشمال الى الجنوب
الى جيزان
للنفود يعني في امكانيات غير عاديه
وبفضل الله اليوم نراها يعني همم نتائج
هذه
الوضوح في الرؤيه وايش النتائج اول نتيجه
هي انه نحن نعمل على على اول الهدف واضح
وفي ااا
المحبس استخدم طلب مصطلحات الاجنبيه بس
اللي هو القلبناز احنا اليوم عندنا اتحاد
واجماع على تحقيق هذا الهدف زي ما قلت في
السابق في الاول سابقا كان في عمل يعني
اساس انه يكون يعني منصفين لكن العمل كان
فردي الكل يعمل باجتهاد بس من دون اي
تفسير اليوم عندنا هدف موحد همم
واستراتيجيات واضحه نعمل على تحقيق
فاقرار الاستراتيجيه الوطنيه
لطيران همم المدني في همم بدايه 21 لما
قراه بعد ما عرضت على اللجنه العليا للنقل
والخدمات الجنسيه همم فيها مجموعه من
المحددات الرئيسيه
اول هدف انه يكون يعني قبل الهدف كيف تم
الوصول لها تم التنسيق والموامه مع مجموعه
من الاستراتيجيات الاخرى يعني انا ما عمل
في الطيران لوحدي الطيران هو في النهايه
ممكن رئيسي للاقتصاد كثير من اهداف الرؤيا
وبرامج الرؤيه
ستتاثر همم نتائجها اذا ما نجح الطيران
فبالتالي حنا يعني مبكر الرئيسي لكثير من
البرامج لذلك علينا مسؤوليه رخمه وليست
كبيره فقط لان احنا ناجح ان شاء الله فكم
مع استراتيجيه السياحه مع استراتيجيه الحج
والعمره مع استراتيجيه السفر لحركه داخل
الاستثمار يعني جميع وزاره الاستثمار جهات
الاخرى بحيث نتاكد انه استراتيجيه ارقامنا
متسخه مع الارقام همم المستهدفه من جهه
الاخرى يعني 100 مليون مستهد عندنا الان
اهم هدف في الاستراتيجيه يعني اللي هو همم
تحسين تج وسعفر انه المملكه تكون هي قطاع
الطيران فيها يكون هو القطاع الرائد في
منطقه الشرق الاوسط
وهذا انا اليوم اشترتيبنا هل نعرف الترتيب
اليوم احنا يمكن اربعه ثلاثه اربعه خمسه
يعني يعتمد على وين تنظر هل هو في
المطارات هل هو في الناقلات احنا نبغى
نكون على جميع المؤشرات الرئيسيه سواء في
عدد المسافرين في عدد الطائرات في الشاحنه
الجوي في الربط الجوي في عندنا مجموعه
مؤشرات اول مؤشر اللي هو عدد المسافرين
احنا في عام دائما عندنا 2019 اسئله
الاساس
في 2019 وصلنا الى حوالي 103 مليون مسافر
من خلال 29 رمضان ولكن كانت الاعمال يعني
مشتته السعوديه تطير هنا وتطير هنا وناس
تطير ويعني ما كان في وضوح في ما يسمى
بالمطارات المحوريه
الجديده تتكلم عن انه سنصل الى 330 مليون
مسافر يعني ثلاثه اضعاف الرقم الحالي
وفي 2030 بيحول الله
ويكون عندنا محوريين الرئيسيين احد
الاشكلات السابقه يعني لما تيجي من نماذج
اللي عندك في المنطقه او حتى في العالم
تجد دائما في مهمه بين الناقل وبين المطر
في المطار لا يمكن يعمل همم في عده مطارات
وشتت جهوده لا من ناحيه جدوله الرحلات
الان من ناحيه العلاقه مع المطار لان
ناحيه الصيانه
الكثير من الرابط شبكه الطيران كلها
مرتبطه الى نجاح المطار ونجاح
اللي هو في انه يكون فيهم بينهم زي
البارتر شفوي او المهمه وهذا الموجود في
هيثرو بريتش ارز
فرانكفورت مع الاوفتانزا عندك المنطقه دبي
الاماراتيه
مع اسطنبول دبي الاتحاد مع الدول
الاماراتيه مع دبي قطريات وهكذا سنغافوريه
في في سنغافوره وهكذا لذلك همم لكن
المملكه الطبيعيه الجغرافيه مختلفه فلذلك
همم تم همم يعني وضع استراتيجيه بحيث انه
يعاد تم وضع خطوط السعوديه احنا تركز
اعمالها في جده لخدمه سواء المحطات
الخارجيه او الداخليه ولكن من من مطار
محوري او حب واحد يكون حواليك جميع
الخدمات من همم
او تمويل او اي خدمات ارضيه او مطار
والعلاقه عشان تكون هب- تحتاج كثير من
الخاص تحتاج عمل كبير تحت الارض في موضوع
عمليه نقل ال- ال- ال- الشنط من طياره الى
طياره برضه حتى موضوع الوقود يفرق سعره
وانت لما تكون عندك تكون في مطار واحد
هتحصل على يعني حجم كبير من الثلاث احصلها
تخفيض فيها مزايا كثيره واهم ترى اللي
ذكرته قبل شويه اللي هو الموضوع همم نقل
الحقائب والتعامل معها هذا انت بتعمل في
موضوع ترانزيت وسرعه النقل من تبقى 45
دقيقه تنزل وتطلع لما يسمونه في الطيران
طيران
45 دقيقه تعمل لي الصيانه ويعمل التموين
ويطلع الركاب واطلع مره ثانيه الطيران
يستفيد المطار يستفيد الخدمات الاخرى
تستفيد
والمسافر يستفيد منه ما يتعطل ينتظر نصف
ساعه فرن عشان انه والله يفتح الباب
الاخير
وهذه يعني انت الان عشان اروح على البلد
معين لازم اروح اوقف فيه في موضوع اخر شيء
ترانزيت محطتين احنا الان هدفنا تتجاوز ال
250 وجهها حول العالم من المملكه مباشره
سواء طبعا من خلال الناقلات الوطنيه او من
خلال الناقلات الاخرى يعني بس ان يكون
عندك فعلا ربط جوي يمكن يعني هذا يصبر
برضه في تجربه المسافر لانه انا ليس سافر
الى عده محطات وتسمح لنا ابو عبد الله
وقفك واسال يعني يحتاج افهم شو اللي كان
يمنع يعني او شيء اللي كان يدفع المسافر
السعودي انه يروح
ياخذ ترانزيت ويتعطل في مطار دبي عشان
يروح لمطارات او لوجهات اخرى بينما كان
الاسهل والاجدده انه ينطلق من المدينه ايش
اللي كان يمنعنا من فتحه وجهها جديده هل
هي مشكله في المشغل والمشكله في الطيران
المدني ولا مش مشكله اعتقد مجموعه من
العوامل انت الاول طبعا همم
السعوديه كانت من زمان تطلع باريس تطلع
لندن تطلع هذه موجوده لكن هل كان في عدد
الطائرات الكافي اللي لانه كانت برضه من
ضمن اشكاليات السعوديه السعه المقادير
كانت ما هي ما كانت كافيه اضافه لانه كانت
مطالبه انها تقدم خدمات لمحطه نموذج مختلف
انا اخدم محطات قد يكون العائد فيها غير
مجدي او نحنا بنسمي في الطيران نسبه
الحموله
لاسباب مختلفه فهي اليوم لما تعيد التموضع
وتركز اعمالك وكذلك النقطه الثالثه اللي
ما يعني كانها تجيب على السؤال انه همم
انشاء ناقل الوطنيه الجديد يكون مقر في
الرياض فصال عندك مطرين محوريين يحققون
فيما بينهم على الاقل 70%
من ال من المستهدفات من ناحيه وشوائم
مستخدمات الاعداد او مستحتفات
في مطار الرياض او طيران الرياض الجديد
هذا مفترض انه مسؤول عن 100 مليون من
الهدف او اكثر او اكثر او مطار جده او
خطوط السعوديه مسؤوله عن مئه مليون
الثالثه
الهدف الثاني الهدف الثالث طبعا الشهد
والخدمات الجنسيه شحن الجوي المملكه زي ما
ذكر في انه المملكه هي المستهدفه انها
تكون يعني همم مقر رئيسي همم وهب للخدمات
اللوجستيه والشحن في في المنطقه تربط بين
القارات الثلاث
فالشاحن الجوي والخدمات اللوجستيه والقرى
القرى الشاحن القرى الجديسيه هذا احد
الاهداف الرئيسيه احنا في عام 2019 مره
ثانيه بقتلهاش وصلنا الى حوالي همم
800,000 طن عندنا تشريب الحركه ضخم جدا
الشحنات تصل الى بعض الدول المجاوره وتدخل
عندنا عن طريق البرد
لاسماء باسباب يعني عدم وجود اااه قرى شحن
مناسبه الاجراءات كانت كذلك غير امواتيه
همم تم وضع هذا من اهم الاهداف انه انه
نصل الى اربعه ونص مليون طن له نعم 20 30
كم اليوم
وهذا يعني بنكون من يعني من اكبر ال- خمسه
دول في في مجال النقل الشحن الجوي في
المنطقه طب هذه الطلب عمل رضا رقم سواء في
الاجراءات في التشريعات في القرش الشحن في
المناطق الجنسيه واللي تتحقق اللي هو
سمعته عنها المنطقه الجنسيه الخاصه
الملك خالد في الرياض بمساحه 3 مليون متر
اللي مع شركه ابل هذا صراحه يعني نقل
نوعيه في انك تستقطب شركه ابل والان في
عندنا قائمه طويله من من اكبر 100 شركه في
قطاع ال- ال-
الشحن والخدمات الجنسيه ل- همم
الاستقطابهم للمنطقه لانبحث انها تكون
منطقه تقدم خدمات ال- ال- همم منطقه الشرق
الاوسط وافريقيا في هذا المجال اللي
وصلتنا ابو عبد الله من احد الاشخاص يعني
المهتمه على استراتيجيه يقول متى تنشرون
الاستراتيجيه كامله يعني اللي منشور هو
فقط رؤوس اقلام منها هل عندكم نيه تنشرون
الاستراتيجيه مفصله في ناس كثير مهتمين
فيها ممتاز احنا يعني السؤال الاول يمكن
اللي هو الجهات اللي تعمله عندنا طبعا همم
قطاع مهم من ضمن قطاعات الهيئه اللي هو
قطاع الاستراتيجيه
نعقد وطبعا ضمن الجهاز وانقطاع فريق معني
بتفعيل الاستراتيجيه ومن ثم استراتيجيه
وناقيد اجتماعات طبعا شهريه وربع سنويه مع
جميع القطاعات اللي في اللي في القطاع
الطيران اخر اجتماع كان في
منتجع الوصيل حوالي اقل من اسبوعين كان في
اكثر من 50 مشارك
شركات الطيران شركات الخدمات الارضيه
الصيانه همم الشركات الشحن جميع الجهات
اللي تعمل في القطاع نشاركها
بالاستراتيجيه والاهداف وانا اعطي كل لقاء
فرصه لثلاثه اربع شركات تعمل زي ال-
التركيز على همم وين وصلوا وش همم طباعهم
بالاستراتيجيه الوطنيه
احنا عندنا عشرات المبادرات همم
اكثر من مئه مبادره تحت الاستراتيجيه نعمل
عليها بالعكس همم يعني احنا همم زي ما
بدانا في نشر التقارير الخاصه يعني حلوه
المسافرين واداء المباراه
في في مجموعه من المؤشرات ونبدا انشرها
ويتحقق اللي همنا بصراحه واللي يتاب اطعم
دائما من اللجنه العليا همم برسوم اللي
قاعد الله يحفظه واصحاب المعالي هو الان
احنا بدانا وراح احنا دخلنا 23 باقي سبع
سنوات اناشيد 30 وين وصلنا يعني طبعا تعرف
بالرغم من ال من ال يعني الانخفاض اللي
حصل في ال في همم في همم
يعني على سبيل المثال احد المستهدفات اللي
عندنا بالارقام انه 30 مليون معتمر
همم 28 30
احنا اليوم هل ترى يمكن نتوقع احنا نصل 30
مليون على حسب الارقام اللي احنا ماشيين
عليه اليوم
وهذا اللي تعودناه من القياده الله يحفظهم
لذلك الارقام ان شاء الله ستنشر وتشارك مع
مع يعني المهتمين لانه فعلا هسه ان شاء
الله بحول الله تعالى
[موسيقى]
في يعني يمكن اهم مبادرات تحقيق او ممكنات
تحقيق الاستراتيجيه هو مطار الملك سلمان
الى اعلن عن مخططه قبل قبل اسابيع قليله
يعني هذا المطار في اسئله على ليش اقيم في
نفس موقع مطار الملك خالد ليش ما كان في
موقع اخر جنوب الرياض يخدم حجم رياض اللي
قاعد يتمدد ليش سته مدارس في المطار عدد
ضخم من المدارس كم سعه اللي بنصرف 20 30
كم السعر اللي بعد ذلك لو تعطينا اللي
تقدر تعطيني اياها على المطار طبعا
المطار همم في طبعا لجنه او مجلس تاسيس
للاشراف على المطار
سوريا
العامه
والاسئله اتفضلت فيها يعني هي اغلبها
دروسها بالتفصيل يعني الموقع في افضل هنا
ولا مكان اخر
الساعه
فبرست جميع
الاجراءات الملاحيه ااا
العدد المسافرين
وكذلك في مشاركه مع الهيئه العليا الملكيه
لتطوير مدينه الرياض والارقام المستحدثه
للسياح الزوار رجال الاعمال يعني في
دراسات مستفيده سواء على حسب العرض والطلب
للمسافرين الموقع وبالتالي تم همم بعد
مفاضله من عده خيارات انه الموقع الحالي
هو في في مزايا كثيره همم يمكن اعتقد من
اهمها انك انت اليوم المطار بعد فتح صار
ثلاثه واربعه همم
يصل الى حوالي 40 مليون مسافر
وفي صاله توسعه لصاله خمسه قادمه ان شاء
الله بحيث انه نصل 20 مليون مسافر اخر
يعني انت ما تستطيع ان تنتقل من من طبعا
هو المستهدف 120 مليون في 20 30 ب اربع
مدارس
185 مليون 20 50 ب 6 مدارس فما تستطيع ان
في 20 30 تطلع من من 40 الى الى 120 فجاه
لذلك التدرج في الحركه وجودك في مطار قائم
في كثير من الخدمات سواء خدمات الارضيه
الصيانه ال- ال- البنيه التحتيه من لوتشر
وكهرباء وهمم
وخدمات وقود همم ما في شك انها عوامل
ايجابيه وتؤخذ عاله في الاعتبار في تقييم
جدول هذا حتى في ابها يعني همم كان في
مفاضله بين انه الموقع اخر نفس الموقع
هذا المطار صار مملوك
صاله العامه وبطبيعه الحال همم لو رجعنا
للقرار 170 49 اللي تكلمت عنه اللي هو
خالد الطريق
لتخصيص الطيران القطاع الطيران المرحله
الاخيره هي النقل
جميع نقل مطارات بعد ما نقلها كل الاصول
مثلا عندنا مطارات هي صندوق
صندوق الهيئه اللي نقلنا لها كل الاصول
واليوم ممنوع كل الحقيقه
الاصول والموظفين والعقود والاراضي الخطوه
الاخيره من
الامر الثاني هي نقل المطارات بما لها
وعليها الى صديق عامه
الربحيه ولا انكم انتم تكملون هي في عندنا
مطارات جاهزه للانتخابات
في الرياض في الدمام همم
عندنا كذلك همم مدينه كل هذه بطلت جاهزه
للانتقال خلال الشهر القادم الصندوق
ستاليها مطارات الاخرى تبعه وفي الحديث عن
مطار الرياض الجديد دائما ييجي الحديث عن
الخطوط الطيران الجديده وهنا كان فيه يعني
يمكن تعرضت عليها قبل شوي بس الان محتاج
نوضعها اكثر ااا خطوط الطيران الجديده
اللي يعني انتشر انه اسمريه
صحيح ولا لا لكن الفكره هي ان
كثير يقولون حطوا حيلكم في خطوط السعوديه
نجحوها هذه اريد فيها 100 طياره فيها
موظفينها فيها ال ال يعني اسمها ليش بدل
ما نحط جهدنا على تطبيق خطوط السعوديه
رحنا نستثمر في خطوط جديده ونشتري طيارات
في الوقت للقطاع كله عليه ضرابيه ويمكن
صعوبه ان هذا الوليد الجديد يقدر ينافس
عالميه في وقت قصير وبدي اسمع وجهه نظرك
في فكره انشاء خطوط جديده بدل من التركيز
على تطوير الخطوط السعوديه طبعا همم
الطيران الجديد هو تحت اشراف العامه
ان شاء الله قريبا
بالنسبه لوجهه النظر نحنا نتكلم عن 330
مليون مسافر نتكلم عن 250 ويمكن حتى 300
وجه ومحطه خارجيه الا يوم الخطوط السعوديه
عندها 1440 طياره وعندها طبعا طلبات قادمه
امم ما اعتقد انه انه الخطوط السعوديه
تستطيع ان لوحدها ان تحقق هذه المستهدفه
توقعات المملكه الجغرافيه موضوع مطارات
المحوريه انك تتواضع في جده وتركز على
المعتمرين والحجاج والمحطات الخارجيه همم
لن يحقق الهدف احنا ركزنا على الخطوط
ودعمناها ما تقدر
من المهم انه تكون فيه همم خطوط ثانيه على
ما يسمى بال- يعني نموذج همم الخدمات
الكامله والمتكامله اللي هو الفل سعر بس
همم ممكن بعدين نعالج على موضوع الخدمات
المنخفضه التكاليف لكن هي نموذج همم
مهم وجوده مهم ليه تحقيق اتكلم عن 100
مليون هنا 120 120 مليون لا بد يكون عندك
مطاعم ناقل وطني همم بينه وبين المطاعم
اذا المطاعم سيسر الامير ال 185 مليون لا
يمكن ان ينجح المطار في تحقيق هذه الاهداف
من دون ان يكون في شراكه قويه
مع نقل وطني قوي موضوع
الخطوط الجديده يذكرنا او يفتح في بالنا
السؤال حق عدد اللاعبين في القطاع او عدد
خطوط الطيران القطاع يعني خطوط السعوديه
هي الوحيده في المشهد جت فتره فتح الترخيص
لخطوط اخرى
فسمعنا عن عده شركات طيران ذكري ايام
الخياله ناس سما واغلبهم فلسوا وقفلوا الا
شركه ناس هي اللي كملت بعدين فتح المجال
همم الدفعه ثانيه من خطوط نسمه الخليجيه
السعوديه همم
وبرده كثير منهم الان حسب ما يظهر لنا
طلعهم من القطاع اذا احنا نتكلم على بلد
من اليوتيوب على موقع لوجوستي جبار على
طلب هائل متسرب للدول المجاوره ليش الخطوط
اللي تتاسس في السعوديه ما هي قادره تنجح
طيب يعني خلينا نتكلم
التاريخ عن المستقبل يعني لانه تجارب اللي
كانت يعني حصلت سابقا اييي ما اولا طبعا
انقطاع الطيران قطاع صعب
ويحتاج الى يعني عمل مستمر
وحصافه في حساب التكاليف خطوط نموذج
الطيران يجب ان تقرر هل انت هتكون همم
منخفض تكاليف نموذج ولا ولا بتقدم الخدمات
كامله وكل نموذج
المعايير في العمل
وبعض النماذج السابقه للاسف كانت همم
باحد النماذج كان يحاول ان يكون همم منخفض
تكاليف لكن تركيبه الطياره الكونفجره داخل
الطياره
او الخدمات اللي كان يقدمها
كذلك الشبكه وين تعمل
كثير من نماذج السابقه ما وفقت همم يمكن
نموذج الوحيد اللي عندنا اليوم اللي هو
يعني استمر
المراحل اديل اليوم عندنا النموذج اخر
يعني ناجح ان شاء الله انه يستمر همم
الشركتين الاخرى اللي هي الخليجيه
السعوديه بالنسبه للاسف هم طبعا
بتوقيت كاس اسيا جاءت الكرونه وكان هم لسه
باديين وعلى فكره ترى هم ما يعني ما خرجوا
السوق هم طلبوا همم في ذلك الوقت لقاء او
يعني تجميل او لو للرخصه لمده معينه والان
في اجتماعات بيننا وبينهم همم
نقدموا لنا خطط خلال سنوات الخمس الخادمه
طموح الحقيقه فيها برامج ممتازه على موضوع
سواء الشبكات او الطائرات
همم استقطها همم للعامل مره اخرى بس يعني
الحجم بالحجم السعوديه وقطاع الطيران فيها
كم المفروض يكون عندنا يعني شركه طيران
شوف في دراسه عملناها مؤخرا واحنا الان
يعني بصدد هذا الموضوع انه ندرس تعرف انت
في النهايه ما تبغى تصل الى ما حصل في
امريكا في السبعينات دخلت عشرات الشركات
صارت حرب اسعار اللي سافر يعني تكون شباب
ماذا سافرت في الثمانين ذات الوقت بس حتى
يمكن بدايات السيارات
الخدمات كانت جدا متدنيه في الطائرات
الامريكيه
تبغى تاخذ مثلا عصير تدفع دولارين
والان في بعضهم بيتكلموا ان اجلكم والله
حتى لو تبغى تروح الحمام تتفاعل فلوس بعض
الناقلات فكانت الخدمه جدا بس يعني متدنيه
حصلت حرب اسعار خرجوا كثير من اللاعبين
وحصل بعدين عمليات استحواذات وتم اعاده
ترتيب السوق طبيعيا يعني ليس من متدخل
مباشر وغيرها لكن لذلك احنا اهل استعمل
عندنا انه كم عدد اللاعبين المناسب في
دراسه عملت
في النتيجه تقول لك انه والله اولا تقارن
كم عدد السكان مساحه ال ال ال ال الدوله
عدد المطارات عدد المطارات وتقيس كم ناقل
موجود نسبه للعدد السكان
افرج عشره
ثلاثه
بس هذا الطائرات قليل
فبالتالي كم طائره لكل المليون
يسمونها دن سيتي
الافريج حوالي ثمانيه ونص حنا تقريبا
95/10/6 برده كذلك في قياس عرض الطائرات
اذا قلنا اليوم عند 240 طائره بين نتكلم
عن تجاريه بين السعوديه وناس وهديل
في برده قياس ثاني يسموا البروفين سيتي
اللي هو يقيس يعني رغبه السفر
والقدره الشرائيه واحنا ما شاء الله تعرف
السعوديه ما شاء الله السفر يعني وهذا
الله يديم ان شاء الله تجدهم دائما يعني
المحبين للسفر فبالتالي هذا برده في
المؤشر احنا همم
المؤكد انه نحتاج الان هل نحتاج
10 10
بس
الطائرات عندك عالي فبالتالي مش ضروري
العشره اللي المعادله اللي طلعنا فيها
التقريبيه اليوم اثنين الى ثلاثه ينقصها
ثاني ثلاثه خطوط ثلاثه خطوط واغلفهم يعني
في في التكاليف المنخفضه
اللي دعم حقيقه الدعم ال همم الهابس يعني
الدعم المطارات المحوريه لدعم اعمال
السعوديه في همم في جده لدعم اعمال للنقل
الوطني الجديد في الرياض همم تحتاج على
الاقل اثنين ويكون برده بتتاكد وين وين
وين يكون محارهم هل يكون زي السابق واحد
في حائل واحد في ابها الدمام بصراحه من
المطارات المهمه اللي نعمل على صراحه كثير
والله
ههه بس بمعنى بنتكلم عن الطلاق اقتصادي هل
ممكن نشرح يعني همم ايش يعني طيران
اقتصادي وايش بالضروره همم
مستوى المعرفه اللي لازم يعني همم او
الوعي اللي يحتاج الشخص على هذا الطيران
لان في صوره دهنيه انه طياره صاعدي لازم
يكون رخيص رخيص جدا وهذا المفهوم الاساسي
بس لما نيجي اليوم نفسه اقتصادي في
السعوديه تذاكر عاليه او او مرتفعه مثلا
همم تلاقي مثلا موضوع الحقائب ما يحق لك
انك تشحن حقيبه الا بمبلغ ففي يعني همم
مفاهيم مغلوطه عن هذا الطيران وايش
النموذج اللي تعتقد انه سليم في الاقتصادي
نقدر نعتبرها فرصه نوع الناس على همم
استيعابه شوف ثمن الاقتصادي همم طبعا
موضوع الاسعار على الموضوع مختلف يمكن
لكن الطيران اقتصادي همم نموذج يختلف
بالكامل عن الطيران المقدم خدمات
المتكامله اولا في نوعيه الطائرات اللي هو
دائما استخدم الطارده همم بدل الضيق
مقارنه البدن العريض يعني همم ويكون
الطائرات غالبا موحده لانه هذه تساعد في
تصميم المقاعد ان تكون واحده صاعد تساعد
في ترينغ او تدريب للكرول المضيفات
المضيفين الليمون على الخدمه انهم معرفه
الطائره ما تحتاج انك تعمل انك تدريب اخر
الكباتنه كذلك والتشغيل الصيانه قطع
الغيار فتوحيد النموذج همم يساعد على
تخفيض التكاليف فهذا هذه السنه الرئيسيه
ال- السماء الاخرى موضوع الخدمات التي
تقدم داخل الطائره عند كراسه طريقه مساحات
اللي امامك ضيق همم فتلاقي الطياره محشوره
بالكلام هذا النموذج اللي عنده دائما
صحيح فهذا من ضمن ال ال ال ال
الخصائص اللي تعمل لتخفيض التكلفه وزياده
العدد بس مش الخدمات المفترض انها تكون
بلاش مش الخدمات اللي مفهوم انها تكون
بمقابله الان تيجي لموضوع الخدمات تقدم
داخل الطياره الاكل يعني مثلا الخدمات
المتكامله تجد فيها كل المطبوخ في حين
يكون عندك كشف الطياره مثلا همم مسخن
الاكل ويقدم مجانا هذه ما فيها اكل
همم ما فيها همم خدمات ترفيه انت يعني ما
تجد فيه شاشه ما عندك 100 فيلم تتفرج
عليهم كلها هذه مش موجوده وهذه قد يكون
حلها الان البسيط مع الايباد والتقنيه
يعني لكن كل الخدمات هذه داخل الطائره ليه
الهدف منها ليش يعطيك السعر يقول لك والله
انا اعطيك سعر 200 ريال
الخطوط الثالثه هو لازم طبعا هذا كل
الخدمات داخل الطائره غير موجوده
الخدمات الاخرى اللي خارج هي موضوع ال ال
وهي ثقه في الطياره وين تنزل في مطارات
الرئيسيه تجددها ما تنزل فيها لانه تكلفه
المطارات الرئيسيه اول المزحومه ما يعطي
خانات زمنيه بالشكل المطلوب واجارات
ايجارات اعلى وحتى لو نزل في المطار يروح
في الساحه ويطلع ويركب بتطلع ركاب باص بدل
ما يركب على الجسر لانه الجسر اغلى من
الباص
او يروح المطار بعيد همم ارخص من كثير
اللي ما عنده حركه تقول له تعال انزل
مجانا
في اي مكان او في في جميع مراحل همم
العمليه فهذا الان الشركات المنخفض
عندها ميزان او يعني تميز او صفه مهمه
اللي هي هي تعمل على ربحيه الخط وليس
بحياه الشبكه
يعني هو يفتح خط جديد وتلاقيه غامر ينزل
اسعار بشكل كبير تتفاجئ منها طبعا هو يامل
انه مع الوقت بس لو لو ما يربح ممكن يسكر
خط بكره وتجد حالات كثيره اليوم ونسمع عن
امثله كثيره في دول اخرى يعني وطيران اخر
انه والله فجاه انت حاجز همم جئت المطار
قال لك
او اذا كانوا يعني بعد ممتازين اتصلوا
عليك وبلغوك اذا ما وصل الى لو ادفع اكثر
الى ساعه معينه يلغي فهو ينظر الى ربحيه
ال الخط وليس لحيه الشبكه الخطوط الطيران
المتكامله تنظر الى ربحيه الشبكه وقد يكون
عنده خطه وخطين خسرانين بسويه ينظر لل لل
للمجموعه فكل هذه اوامر
الشنط هو ما يعني لانه طبعا يعتمد على
وزير الطائره وبالتالي حجود لذلك هو يقول
لك انا اذا تبغى ادفع
تدفع تدفع بدايه المواسم وبعدين تطلع
الشغل ليش لانه والله الولد اللي موجود
اكثر من اللي هو ده اللي ممكن تطلع فيه
الطياره
كل هذه اوامر همم
ومهم منه يعني
المسافرين بالفروقات اقتصادي
صحيح كيف تقيم تجربتهم والله انا يعني
التجربه الى اليوم مقارنه يعني بعض الدول
او بعض الخدمات نشوفها في بعض يعني الى
الان همم تجربه جيده ممكن تتحسن اكثر
من اللي اشوف هم قاعدين يعملون على يعني
تحسينات كبيره يعني لا اديل ولا ناس في
موضوع مثلا ناس اللي يعرف انهم الان عندهم
وصلوا تقريبا 41 42 طياره عنده 13 طياره
قادمه العام القادم منها يمكن اربع طيارات
اي 3
في النموذج
دي الكذلك عندها طلبيات ظهرت القادمه يعني
ال- يتطورون تطور المجالس تطور اكبر همم
اعتقد وجود ودخول لاعبين جدد في السوق
لخلق منافسه لفتح خيارات اضافيه لمحطات
اضافيه سيعطي المسافر التنوع في الاختيار
وسيحسن الخدمات لما اسمع كل هذا ابو عبد
الله همم تخيل انه عندنا سبع سنوات عباره
عن طفره في قطاع الطيران كلها اللي ذكرتهم
الثلاثه زائد الخطوط الجديده زائد الخطوط
اللي محتمله تدخل كلهم بيطلبون طلبيات
طائرات بيحتاجون صيانه بيحتاجون كوادر
بشريه فهذه ارقام ضخمه جدا بتؤثر
بالاقتصاد يا انعظم استفادتنا منها ونبطل
الاكبر او نخليها للصدفه وكل واحد يفاوض
لحاله يشتري لحاله فوش الدور اللي سوى
وياها كتنسيق لطلبات الشراء للصيانه تدريب
القواعد البشريه لان واحده من اهدافكم في
الاستراتيجيه حسب ما جريت
تدريب وتاهيل الكفاءه السعوديه لتقود هذا
القطار
وكيف كيف ممكن يعظم
للي تكلمنا فيه على موضوع الاستراتيجي
الاجتماعات الاستراتيجيه وتنسيق
الاستراتيجيه بين القطاعات المنظور بشكل
عام او ما نسميها النبليك والسستم في
الطيران اااه في ممكنه يعني طبعا الشراء
في الان همم فريق او في نقاش على ان يكون
في فعلا تيسير بين على مستوى وطني لانه
اليوم في ضغط كبير انت تعرف في العالم
عندك كثير كثير
عليهم يعني اليوم باكله او السرقه طويل
اقرب من كده لو تبغى اليوم لازم تشتري حصه
من طرف اخر عشان تاخذها
همم يكون في تفسير هذا ما في شك انه في في
عمل عليه
كذلك موضوع الخدمات اللي مطلوبه سواء من
ناحيه تدريب تاهيل الاكاديميات سواء تاهيل
تدريب الطيارين طبعا غير الطيارين
ومساعدين الطيارين عندنا حنا يعني مجموعه
ضخمه من الوظائف اللي تخدم مراحلين
المراقب خدمات جويه فنيين صيانه يعني في
مهام متعدده ناعم على تاهلها وتطويرها
لخدمه همم الحركه المتزايده احد يعني
التحديات الكبرى هي اللي يمكن الصيانه
اليوم
الامارات وفي المملكه خطا خطوات خلال
الاربع سنوات بدا برامج التوازن الاقتصادي
وفي شركات اليوم عندنا طبعا ساعي اللي هي
احدث شركه الخطوط السعوديه للصيانه همم
اليوم عندها مجمع بعض
بجده يحتاج استثمارات وفي برامج على
السيارات
ضخمه بحيث انه فعلا يقدم الخدمات
المتكامله كان في مشروع ضخم يعني تعثر في
وقت الاوقات الان يعني يحتاج دعم وفيه
برامج دعم هذا المجمع ضخم بحيث انه يكون
احد اكبر همم
يعني مواقع الصيانه لتقديم الخدمات في
المملكه اليوم عند تسريب كبير للخدمات
السياره خارج المملكه لما يقام اليوم
داخليا هو الصيانه الخفيفه وتصريفات معينه
لكن ليس بالشكل المطلوب همم كذلك احد
اهداف الاستراتيجيه هي تحرير السوق يعني
اليوم لما نحرر السوق الخدمات الارضيه في
التموين في الصيانه في الشاحن بحيث يكون
عندك تخلق منافسه تحسن الخدمات وتعطي
خيارات يعني احنا اليوم يعني في السابق
كان في عند الممارسات خلينا نكون اني
واقعين كان عنده ممارسه احتكاريه في كثير
من الخدمات اللي كانت تقدم احد اهداف
اليوم الاساسيه نحن فعلا يعني نعالج هذا
شركه همم
افيشن ليز
اوليز هذه بيكملها تنسيق او في علاقه
الصندوق وهي بدون شكل مهم جدا لانه همم
الان نموذج
يعني المشاهدين الكرام انه همم اغلب
الطائرات تشتغل عن طريق اجاره
تكاليف انك تحتاج استثمارات ضخمه ما في
شركه همم بتوعنا ومهم متى هي عمليات تامين
هذا الطائرات باجار سنوي فانت تسير عندك
تكاليف الايجار تكاليف الاعمال التشغيليه
هو الوقود وغيرها من بدل ما يكون عندك
مصاريف راسماليه ضخمه تحت ضخم البدايه
وهكفي فوجود هذا ما بشكلها يكمل همم جزء
اساسي من حوالي الخطوط المختلفه لتوفيق
الطائرات صحيح همم قرات دراسه لاليفر
وايمان نشرتها العربيه في في 2020 انقطاع
الطيران سيواجه نقص حاد
يقدر ب 80000 طيار في عام 20 32 همم
واحنا عندنا في السعوديه همم ناس طيارين
وعاطلين يعني بدي اعرف انا الموضوع موارد
البشريه في قطاع الطيران كم عدد السعوديين
كم عدد وظائف جمالا كم المتوقعه في فتره
القادمه هل تنصح الناس قطاع وتقول لهم ترى
انا مكتفين لا تطردون اعماركم يضيعون
مستقبلكم
احنا طبعا الدراسه
ولكنه بدون شكل وبعد 20 30 هيكون في حاجه
لانه اذا كنا نتكلم عن الناقله الوطنيه
الجديده والنقل تحتاج الى 120
عالميا وليس في السعوديه كويس
احنا اليوم عندنا يمكن 22 هو طبعا تعرف
عند حوالي 22,000 وظيفه حصرناها في قطاع
غزه في قطاع الطيران والشركات اللي تعمل
في قطاع الطائره والمطارات همم منها حوالي
المساعدين الطيارين اليوم 100% السعوديه
يمكن عندنا 60 70% في الكباتنه
هي عمليه تاهيل الطيارين ودخولهم
للقطاع هي اللي تحتاج تنسيق اكثر لكن بدون
شكل راقب هذا الموضوع
يعني نعمل على التاكد من انه جميع الوظائف
المطلوبه سواء طيارين مساعد طيارين مقدمين
خدمات الصيانه الفنيين في المراقبين جويين
يعني العمل في القطاع متشعب وكبير في
برنامج تنسيق بين وزاره النقل وزاره
الموارد البشريه لتوطين مجموعه كبيره في
المستهدفات في 23 في 24 لتوطين مجموعه من
الوظائف في في هذا القطاع فالعمل يعني همم
في تحدي لكن همم اليوم الاشكاليه هو انه
فيه همم عندك العرض يسبق الطلب او الطلب
يسبق العارضه لكن همم مستقبل للوظائف ان
شاء الله انه واحد همم
لا تلمون على اي شيء في الماضي يا ابو عبد
الله لكن يعني الحاضر في عليه كلام يعني
التوقعات كانت عاليه صارت ثلاثه واربعه
مقفله خمس سنوات احنا اليوم في المرحله
اللي فيها معايير عاليه فيها جوده عاليه
فيها همم توقعات المواطنين عاليه فتحت
الصاله انا شخصيا جربتها
مريح انها اكبر وموضوع السيور الطيران
اكبر لكن الصراحه جوده الخدمات فيها مخيبه
اسوء من اللي كان قبر يعني
السوق الحره كانه ناس باصتين وممثله بشكل
مختلف
يعني تذكر البزنس ولا في كل
المطار تستوعب المسافرين درجه الاعمال او
لدرجه الاولى الاضاءه بيضاء احس انه في
المستشفى
رائعه جدا غير هويه المطار طبعا اللي ما
تشبه المطار السابق او مهما يعني شعرت
باني في مكان ما هو المكان السابق وله
افضل من المكان السابق
ااا فكيف تقييمك
لصاله ثلاثه واربعه اللي افتتحت في الرياض
السنه هذه او السنه اللي فاتت
الموضوع
طبعا بدا مشروع توسعه العمل 2017
[موسيقى]
انه كيف تكون عندنا كيف اولا تعرف صار
اربعه
كانت تستخدم
الداخليه وبعد فتح صاله خمسه نقلت همم
الصاله الداخليه الى صاله خمسه وبدا
المشروع ذاك الوقت وكان طبعا تعرف في عده
نتفق معك انه الهويه تغيرت عن يعني صاله
واحد واثنين او ثلاثه سابقا وهويه المطار
المطار الملك خالد يعني
من عام 1988 ولكنه لا يزال يحتفظ برونك
وجمال ذكرياتها فيه يعني اذا شفت المثلثات
استانس استعاده
جزء من ذاكره المدينه لكن اعتقد كانت في
اعتبارات اخذت في ذلك الوقت على موضوع
الفعاليه التكلفه الصيانه بحيث انك انت
همم تدمج همم يعني تم الغاء النوافير
النوافير وانك تتوسع في في همم
المساحات اللي قابل للتاجير مطاعم مقاهي
سوق حره الى اخره همم وكذلك تمج ال- ما
تحت الارض من ناحيه سيور امتع همم جميع
الخدمات اللي بنسميها الالكتروميكانيكال
والتقنيه همم في همم مزايا من هذه الناحيه
التشغيليه المفروض يعني
لكن كانت على حساب كذلك في عندك يعني
سنترا او او منطقه استقبال مسافرين موحده
فيها حوالي 60 شكل كاونتر همم تستطيع ان
تستخدمنا
[موسيقى]
اثنا عشر همم كوثر خاص بالسلف او الشخص
يستطيع اجراءاتك فيها كاونت الخاص بالعفش
الذاتي كذلك يعني
العمليه المرور
الجوازاتها التفتيش كذلك الاجهزه التفتيش
تم همم تركيب احدث همم
الاجهزه فيها صحيح الان الان همم كان في
اعمال لازالت ما استلمت همم لما جاب وقت
ال- همم كاس العالم كان في تحدي امامنا
انه همم كيف نستقبل همم مسافرين ومشجعين
كاس العالم خصوصا في ايام همم مباريات
المنتخب همم وانا اكثر من السعاده اللي
حضر مباراه الارجنتين ههه احنا داي
مباركين ههه لو خلونا يحفظ بقيه المباراه
كان وصلنا بس البلد اللي راح بعدنا يعني
برده التجربه الرحله يعني من خلال المطار
وصار حتى في يعني تعثر للتفتيش في الجهاز
وتوقف خمس دقائق يعني فمريت في كل المراحل
اااه فكانت الفكره انه همم عشان ما نعمل
ضغط على صاله واحد واثنين او نضع مثلا
بصاله خارجيه مؤقته انه نشغل الصاله بشكل
مؤقت
وفعلا تم يعني همم تفويج في المملكه كلها
عموما من حوالي 320,000 مسافر بين الرياض
وجده والدمام الرياض كانت في بعض الايام
تصل الى الى همم الرحله ايام المنتخب همم
طبعا السعوديه وبعضها الجدوله وبعضها وناس
وهذه القطريه فكانت هذه البدايه
الان في اعمال لسه ما شفتهم يعني في
الميزانيه للدور في
طلعت على الدرج الكهربائي مقفله الان في
حوالي 16 مساحه
جاهزه لتجهيزات
للدرجه الاولى انا اتفق معك 100% مو
معقوله تدفع بريميوم او سعر تذكره او اسجد
طبعا تم عمل حل مواقف وصار ثلاثه همم
قفلتوها خليتها داون وحيد العمل يمكن شيء
مشابه بصاله اربعه نحتاج على الاقل سته
شهور الى الان تشتكمل اعمال تعرف يعني مو
قضيه انه احد من اليوم على احد بس او صارت
هذه تجهز لان تؤجل على الطيران
فيتجهز من قبل الناقلات يعني همم الان في
همم واللي كان مجهز صلاه الفرسان الخطوط
السعوديه نفسها فهم لا يقولون ما عندنا
شغل في المطار يعني بس الان كان في يعني
بعض الاجراءات اعتقد المشروع انه يبدا
قريبا يمكن
خلال شهور وفي حل مؤقت يعني خلال اسبوعين
بيكون جاهز لانه من غير مقبول لانه يعرف
اضافه لانه بعض الانظمه لا زال تحت
التشغيل التجريبي يعني تعرف انت في
المطارات
ثلاثه اربعه سته احيانا يعني في مطارات في
المنطقه او في في الماء في اوروبا وغيرها
اسمها اللي تاخذ سنه اللي يسموه للاورات
يعني اللي هو الابريشي
واللي تحتاج لانك فعلا تجهز المطار
وعندك مئات الانظمه
والسستم
المترابطه ومتداخله فيجب انك تتاكد 100%
انا ما هو هذا التبرير لكن هذه يعني احد
الاسباب اللي احنا نعمل على تحسينها ويعود
المطار الى ان يكون تشغيل واعلان عن موضوع
الهويه فيها يعني مشروع قادم لتحسين ان
شاء الله جميل وبعدها يعني احنا افتتحنا
ثلاث اربع مش بيصير في واحد واثنين خمسه
طبعا واحد واثنين تعرف لما 40 سنه ما تم
تحديثه يحتاجون الى تحديث ماخم من ناحيه
ال- اا ال- ال- الانظمه الطيور الكهرباء
[موسيقى]
الاخيره همم في مشروع الان سيبدا خلال
يعني يمكن حسابيع لتحديد صلاه واحده صلاه
واحد ستقفل
والناقلات الاجنبيه اللي كانت فيها ستنتصر
صلاحيه لمده سنه بعد سنه
ستفتح صاله واحد
ويعودون نعيد الناقلات الاجنبيه الى صاله
واحد ونعمل على تحديث اصاله كم الحياه كل
صلاه
سنتين ان شاء الله
انتهاء التحديثات هذه طبعا هيكون خلال
سنوات القادمه في مشاريع همم
توسيعه يعني تضيف زي ال- زي الصلاه
الجانبيه لصاله واحد لصاله اربعه تزيد
ثلاثه اربعه مليون تجديد كاونترات في
البيت
برده ساعه الاستقبال بحيث انه نصل الى
اكثر من 40 مليون مسافر همم في السنه وهذه
كلها ضمن منطقه صالات الملك خالد اللي هي
جزء من مطار الملك سلمان صحيح همم
مطار جده واللي هو هذا
ههه ما ادري ما نبدا صراحه بس اسئله كثيره
اجت عليك مطار جديد ومتحمسين وفرحانين
الناس بعدين تيجي يعني العام الماضي اللي
صار في رمضان كان كارثه كان شيء مخيب
صراحه صادم
ويخدش
شرف وجوده خدمتها نظيف الرحمن الحمد لله
احنا نفتخر فيه لسنوات ثم انت تجيء هذه
المحطه كده الاخيره وتحوس الدنيا صراحه
مؤلمه جدا مؤلمه اكثر لانه كنا لظن انه
المشكله الوحيده في مطار جده هي المطار
نفسه فبني مطار بهذا السعر بهذه ضخامه ودي
افهم مش مشكله مطار جده
طبعا انت اخر مره رحت مطار جده بس عشان
اسالها
يعني
طبعا شوف
اللي حصل في رمضان كان يعني
مخجل بالنسبه
جميعا اتحمل المسؤوليه
يعني لانه ما كان يعني يفترض انه يحصل لكن
لابد في اسباب مش الاسباب الاسباب اولا
العوده السريعه طبعا خلينا نتكلم اولا انه
قابله واحد ما كانت عمله الله بالساعه 30%
فهنا في خلال تم رفع السعه وتجهيز الصاله
بحيث انها تستوعب 30 مليون مسافر
وكذلك كان بالسابق صلاه الحج
طبيعه المعتمرين والحجاج تختلف اختلاف كلي
عن طبيعه المسافرين العاديه
من ناحيه اولا هم يجون افواج يعني جروبات
مجموعات
طبيعه الشنط اللي معاهم مياه زمزم الى
اخره مطار صاله صاله واحد في مطار جده
يعني فيها تقريبا احدث الانظمه لنقل العفش
وفي السيور
خمس مراحل طبعا احنا لسه ما فعلنا المرحله
الخامسه بس المرحله الخامسه تتكلم عن
النسيان يلعب طبعا
المرحله الخامسه طبعا في مراحل تفتيش
تجاوزها او يعني في اجراءات معينه ولكنه
حساس بدرجه انه لابد يكون في الالتزام
بمعايير معينه للشنط انت الحين لما تدخل
مطر في العالم
القياسيه للشنط من ناحيه الحجم من ناحيه
الوزن ولا يسمح لك انك تمررها
فكانت هذه احد المشاكل اللي طبعا المشكله
الي قبل هذه هي موضوع
توفر الطواقم الكافيه للجهات العامله في
الموضوع يعني لان جت بعد كراره مباشره
زامنت العمره مع يعني الناس كان عندهم
يعني رغبه شديده في تعطش للسفر
فالحركه كانت وكنا لا وكانت صاله الحج ما
هي جاهزه فكنا امل انه صارت صاله واحد
بسعتها اللي يعني لما القسمه عدد
المسافرين في رمضان
19 رمضان 21
نظريا وجود صاله واحد مع صاله الشماليه
تكفي
مقارنه بالسابق اللي كان صاله الحجاج صاله
الجنوبيه اللي تحولت خلال الكرونه الى
منطقه يعني
استخدمت وزاره الصحه وكانت مفيده صح لكن
اللي حصل انه ما كان فيه تقييد من قبل
كثير وانا طبعا يعني مسؤوليه الجميع ما
كان في توعيه كافيه ما كان في تفسير كافي
التفويج اللي حصل يعني همم
اعداد كبيره قدموا للصاله همم اعداد يعني
كان تنسيق ما كان بالشكل المطلوب بالجهات
المختلفه من دون ذكر اسماء انا ما بدي
صراحه القمه على احد لكن فعلا هي العمليه
زي ما قلنا في البدايه عمليه تكامليه
وتنسيقيه اذا اختل اي تراهم الاطراف اللي
تعمل في هذه الموضوع عندك مشكله يعني اذا
انا ما اعرف انه والله حيجيني الف مسافر
خلال زمن الوقت الفلاني او اذا وصلوا عندي
والطياره تاخرت لاي سبب من الاسباب يعني
هي عمليه تنسيقيه لا بد تتم بشكل دقيق جدا
اي خلل فيها همم يؤثر على الجميع ففي
اسباب طويله تم يعني همم دراستها
تحقيق فيها و و
معالجتها وفي بعض المشاكسف انا بقول في
مهمه
هي عمليه شهريه اذا عندك موتر يدور اذا
عندك عجله تدور توقع انه هيكون عندكم
مشكله
وايش انه يكون عندك مشكله
تكون عندك مشكله فيها او انها تتكرروا
تتكرر يعني لابد يكون عندك بروتوكولات
واضحه للتعامل مع الحالات المفاجاه فهل
عالجنا ازمه رمضان بالشكل اللي لا نتوقع
ان تكرر بشكل
متطمن ومقتنع بحول الله انه عندنا من الان
الاجراءات طبعا العمل المستمر والتطوير
مستمر لكن اليوم عندنا من الاجراءات
ونفهم من العمل التحديات والتنسيق يعني
احنا فعلنا غرف المراقبه عشرات فوق 75
كاميرا وفي غرفه مراقبه وتحكم تراقب لك
جميع الصالات طبعا احد الاجراءات فعلى
صلاه الحج صلاه الحج كانت تعمل في السابق
فقط همم في همم في همم موسم الحج الان
تعمل طول السنه الاستقبال المعتمرين طبيعه
المعتمرين والحجاج الذي فيها نوعيه الشنط
نوعيه المجموعات كيف التعامل معاهم رحلات
اغلبها عارضه وليست منتظمه لكن كان في ذلك
الوقت تعرف يعني تحديات من ضمنها النقص
ال- سواء النقص عشان نرجع الاشكاليه نقص
الكوادر او قله همم
تاهيل الكوادر يعني انت اليوم ترى بعد في
في شهر مايو العام الماضي احنا قمنا مؤتمر
مستقبل الطياره بعد فتح همم السفر شهر
في الرياض وكان صراحه يعني بفضل الله نجح
نجاح
باهر
وشارك في اكثر من 2000 عضو من من قطاع
الطيران في العالم
ووزراء ورؤساء طيران وكان من ضمن ال ال
النقشات المهمه في احد الهيئات اسمها مجلس
الطيران الدولي
وهذا على فكره
بنات تكون مقر مقر الاقليمي لمجلس الطيران
الدولي في المنطقه همم اللي هو يعني في
عضويتها اكثر من 2000 مطار في العالم
رئيس مجلس الطيران الدولي في ذاك الوقت
المؤتمر طلع بيان صحفي قبل الصيف احنا
نتكلم عن تسعه عشره مايو
ونشروه على جميع المواقع انه يا جماعه ترى
الصيف القادم المطارات الاوروبيه
ازمه كبيره
والاسباب
قبل الاسباب
36% من الطائرات الرحلات تتاخر 16 في
المئه
و15 على الجدولتها الاسباب ما هي قالت نقص
الكوادر المؤهله
بسبب ال ال عمليه ترشيد التكاليف وتشريح
الموظفين الي حصلتهم في المطارات او
الناقلات او شركات الخدمات الارضيه
وذكر في الاخير انه تحتاج 16 اسبوع
اربعه شهور من توظيف
الموظف في هذه الخدمات الى ان يستطيع ان
يبدا يعطيك الخدمه اربعه شهور فيها تاهيل
وتدريب وفيها الاهم اللي هو اللي مسميه
هو اي واحد يعمل في المطار يتعامل مع
المنطقه الحساسه جدا يعني المنطقه المعقمه
امنيه فلذلك الاجراءات انك انك تعيد يعني
استقطاب كفاءات للتشغيل همم بعد الجرح
كانت فيها تحدي كبير
وحتى احنا اللي حضرنا حتى في الرياض في في
بدايه الموسم الصيف لما صار عندنا يعني
ازمه ان عده ساعات
ورصدنا الوقت اللي يعني كان فيه
الكاونترات
استقبال كانت مليئه بالموظفين ما كان في
نقص وبعد ذلك في تكدس ليش يا جماعه
رصدنا الوقت عندنا فريق الجوده وحمايه
المسافرين موجودين معهم
قال لك افرج او المتوسط الموظف اللي اعاده
يعالج او ينهي اجراءات السفر متوسط
دقيقتين ثلاث دقائق اللي موجودين اليوم
لانه جدد جدد يحتاج وقت التاهيل طبعا
التعامل معها من لازم يكون في سوبر واكثر
من واحد اي مشكله تعرف العوده في ذاك
الوقت هل تحتاجها فيزا يعني تعامل مع مع
الوضع في انا ما بدخلك تفاصيل كثيره ولا
يعني همم
المشاهدين الكرام مشاهدات يعني تفاصيل لكن
العمليه ارجع اوه لانه اي خلل في اي جزئيه
يؤثر على الجميع كيف يكون عندنا تحدي
اليوم اللي امامنا كيف يكون عندنا يعني
همم اشراف دقيق على جميع عمليات السفر
وسواء من منشات من صيانه من تشغيل من
ناقلات من جهات التعامل مع الجهات الاخرى
تتبشر اهل جده يعني انا صراحه اتذكر من
الصدف الجميله اللي ادت او او ساهمت فيها
الحلقه اني كنت في الطياره جنب بريد ومنها
صار الحديث وقالت لي انه انت كان عندك
رحله اسبوعيه الى جده فتره ما بين رمضان
الى الحج صح كنتوا تقرفون كل المنظومه في
مطار جده يعني اسبوعيا
على طول طبعا وبالتالي هل احنا قدرنا ازمه
وبس واللي احنا عالجنا الجذور ولا نتوقع
تكرارها يعني وش نقول لها الجده بخصوص
مطارهم المشغل جوده الخدمات الموجوده الى
اليوم الناس تروح احيانا بالباص وهذا شيء
غير مفهوم مطالب الحجم ده بوابات فاضيه
طبعا الموضوع الباص له تفصيل يعني هو نرجع
قبل شوي هل هو على اي طيران طالع وهل هو
يعني ترى الباص هذا من
الاشياء اللي دائما تجينا فيها يعني
تحديات الناس تتصل انا وصلت في الساحه
وركبوني في باص
متعدده يعني تشغيليه يعني يا اما انه اصلا
ناقله طلبه باص لانه في رحله لاحقه هتطلع
من مكان اخر من ظنون الطياره من مكان الى
اخر فهذه الامور الشهريه او انه البوابه
اللي هو يقف عليها ااا عليها طياره اخرى
حصل فيها عطل فني ما اقلش الوقت او يعني
فيه عدد كبير من الاسباب اللي اللي
اكل الباصات تراها لا زالت مطلوبه في جميع
العالم حتى الموتورات الجديده فيها فيها
جسور وفيها بوابات لخدمه الباصات يعني
والناقلات ال- ال- التكلفه المنخفضه دائما
تطلب منها تستخدمه يعني لانها اقل تكلفه
بس اللي المهم في الموضوع انه مطار اهم
نقطه انه نجد العليا للخدمات الجنسيه
اقرت همم المخطط العام لمطار جده
مطر جدا تكلم احنا نتكلم عن 114 مليون
مسافر بحلول العام 20 30 اليوم كم اليوم
تقريبا 40 40
جده شركات كلهم مشاركين في اعداد المخطط
العام باذن الله يكون في مناطق ترفيه في
مناطق سكنيه همم في القرى الشحن في منطقه
جنسيه خاصه زي اللي موجوده في الرياض
ففيه مشروع ضخم جدا تم اقرار يعني كان
الانسان نعمل على المخطط العام في صاله
رقم اثنين في صاله رقم ثلاثه في قد تكون
صاله مخصصه
للناقلات اللي اقل تكلفه عشان تطلع من قصه
همم بوابه
صارت الحج كيف يتم تطويرها تستوعب الاعداد
والتمارين والحجاج القادمين ففيه تطوير
ضخم قادم لكن الاهم اليوم الان هو كيف همم
همم نحسن الاداء الحالي اذا عندنا عمل
مستقبلي وعندنا عمل قائم يعني انت سالت
على موضوع الزياره الاسبوعيه او الاقامه
هناك الى الاهم منه كيف يكون عندنا انظمه
عمل طبعا احنا تعرف بعد منافسه طويله ما
عده شركات وقعنا مع احد الشركات العالميه
للمساهمه في اداره المطار
وناقل المعرفه في اداره المطار واعمال
المطار وهذا الشركه والشنسيتها الانديه
هي الان المشغل لمطار همم
كفاءات سعوديه مؤهله صراحه
وجديره الحقيقه وانا يعني حمر في ايام
الازمات يعني تشوفوا الامكانيات شوف
الرجال يعني ابناءنا وبنات الامثله يعني
شفتها انا شخصيا في اوقات الازمات الله
يشيع يعني احيانا تدمع عينك من كيف حرص
هذا وللابناء الواحد لما يشوف هذول اب
البنات اللي موجودين في هذه المواقع يطمن
على مستقبل البلد همم الله يقويكم انا
يعني مستمتع جدا بالحديث بس اني لازم
اعطيه الاصدقاء ثقاف حقهم عندنا مجموعه
اسئله وصلت ما اظنها غريبه عليك ههه لكن
خليني ابدا باول واهم سؤال عشان تاخذ وقتك
وراحتك الاجابه على اليمن مقاطعك فيه لان
سؤال مره مهم ملح هذا مغرد يعني معروف
اسمه احمد ابن كفيل يقول يوم خلص رمضان
قالت هيئه الطيران ابشروا وبندق في موضوع
ارتفاع الاسعار هذه حوستنا كل سنه ان الله
احياني وما تقفل حسابي بحفظ التغريده
لرمضان القادم وذكركم فهو الان ترى جاهز
ينتظرك في رمضان الجاهلي موضوع الاسعار
همم كثير يسالون عنا كثير يعني متضايقين
من القفز اللي صارت في الاسعار شو بدي
اسمع تعليقك على هذا الموضوع وهل هو اصلا
اختصاصاتكم او اهتماماتكم انكم تخافوا
الاسعار وتحدونها
الموضوع الاسعار موضوع جدا مهمه
يمثل الناس كلهم بالنسبه لنا هو اولويه
الحقيقه بالتعامل معها الان اييه
ومعقد في نفس الوقت مركب يعني ايش اسباب
عشان نفهم ايش اسباب الاسعار طبعا خلينا
من رمضان اللي راح وانه كان اصلا عوده
سريعه وبعد ازمه وشرحناه لكن تركيبه
الاسعار في في
الناقلات ترتبط او لازم يفرق بيننا
قراءه اللي يعني مكتمله الخدمات وانقلات
اللي هي اقتصاديه لانه تركيبه التكلفه
مختلفه همم لكن هو يعتمد على عده عوامل
وقت الشراء
وقت التذكره وقت سفرته يعتمد على
بالنسبه للناقله كم باعوا من الطائره لانه
فيه لا يعتدمر عده سنوات طورت نظام شرائح
في تقريبا 16 شريحه
ومرتبط النظام بحساب عمليه خوارزميه يعني
تتدخل فيها بشري جزئيه لتحديد التكاليف او
الشرائح سعر الشريحه لكنه هو يساعد
الطيران بانها في البدايه في اول ست سبع
شرائح يعني مثلا اذا كانت خطوط همم خدمات
متكامله زي السعوديه مثلا تلاقي عندها 11
شريحه في السياحه وبعدين اربعه في البزنس
وبعدين في الاولى اذا كانت اقتصادي لتجدد
اغلب 16 كلها في الموزعه على الاقتصادي
وهي تبدا تحسب اول عشر او 9% مثلا
منخفض وبعدين بالتدريج يطلع يطلع الى ان
يصل الى اعلى مستوى
في الوقت يعني وقت الشراء وقت السفر هو له
تاثير العنصر الاخر هو الوقود الوقود
اليوم هو من اهم تكاليف
ناقلات يعني يتراوح بين 35%
لناقلات
المتكامله الى تقريبا 55 الى 60
اللي حصل في مقارنه بين 19 و21 قلت لها
الوقود ارتفاع 60%
فهذا تاثير مباشر على تكلفه الطيران
تقطع بالكفاءات الجديده
والتضخم اللي حاصل يعني في عناصر تكلفه
الوقت والموس يعني انت مثلا اليوم
تبغى تحجز هوتيل في لندن ولا تبغى تحجز
هوتيل في مكه
مع التقدير
المقارنه ومكه في رمضان
الاسعار
وتشوف اسعار التذاكر مثلا من الرياض الى
جده ولا من الرياض من الدمام الى جده في
ابريل او في اخر مارس الى حد ما مقبوله
همم ولو انها في رمضان همم في هي العمليه
مرتبطه بعوامل متعدده همم لكن احنا دورنا
انه كمشرع او منظم للطيران لانه نتاكد انه
فيه اول ما فيه ممارسات احتكاريه
لانه في بعض الخطوط ما عليها ناقه الواحد
نرجع مره اخرى
اضافيه لابد يعني احد اهم اسباب
سيطره على الاسعار
اليوم تتدخل بكره بس هذا ما هو حل الحل
فعلا انه يكون فعلا انت تقدم للمسافر
خيارات متعدده من ناقلات مختلفه اوقات
مختلفه
همم احنا الاسباب الاساسيه هو نقص السعه
المقادير تتعبي المقاعد بالتالي ما فيهم
هو بالنسبه له باقي 10% منها
طبعا احنا نراقب الحقيقه ال- ال- الدخان
في التسعير
اليوم مالك دخل بشكل مباشر لكن وجه
شوف
المملكه قائمه الاقتصاد الحره
كانت الاسعار مقننه لكن هذا ما يخدم
الصناعه اليوم اذا حطيت سقف للاسعار ما
تستطيع المستثمرين
اليوم في بعض المسارات في مساره او برنامج
المسارات الالزاميه وهذا وهذا مقر مقر
قريبا وكان له ان هذا السابقه باشكال
مختلفه انه في بعض المسارات داخل المملكه
همم
مهما عملت ما يمكن انه
السعه تزيد عن اسمه معين وبالتالي لن يقدم
عليها اي ناقل يعمل على التجاريه
فوافقت الدوله وقرت انه تدعم هذه المسارات
من خلال النخلات الوطنيه لتامين ال ال
المسارات هذه مستمريه هذا هذا جزء يعني
ودور اصيل الدوله في نعتدعم
تنميه اجتماعيه وتنميه الاقتصاديه لكن في
المقابل دورنا احنا كمنظم انه يكون في
خيارات متعدده يكون في ناقلات متعدده
وتاكد انه في فعلا همم
سعه مقاديه تغطي اكثر من الطلب اللي موجود
همم على نفس الموضوع الاسعار كثير يجي
سؤال وبعدين يمكن يمكن لو قدرت يعني
تبسطها تشرحها للناس بشكل مختصر بيكون
جميل اللي هي كيف احيانا السفر ترانزيت
همم لدوله شقيقه او مثلا شخص جاي من من
مصر ولا من عمان ترانزيت جده رايح لندن
ارخص مني انا طالع من جدا مباشره لندن
غريبه هذه موجوده ترى في كل الخطوط
العالميه هي عمليه الترانزيت وانه انت
اولا انا انت لما تروح رحله مباشره مقارنه
بتروح الرحله فيها توقف في ناس يقول لك
انا ما اتفهم اكثر
لانه السعر بالنسبه له كل سنه نعترف على
حسب يعني امكانياته فهي دائما الرحلات
اللي فيها توقف يصير يصير انا باتكلم عن
جد اتكلم بشكل عام حتى لو تدخل على مواقع
مختلفه تجدها همم تجد انه همم
الطيران باقي عنده 10% ما تخططت فهو يعني
يعطي فرصه اللي همم
خطوط الاخرى ان همم تغطى هذا فهو هذا يعني
ممارسه موجوده في كثير من الطيران همم
نسبه معينه من المقاعد ومرتبطه بانك تقف
في محطتين او اكثر ثلاث همم في تغريده
عجيبه لوزير الشؤون الاسلاميه قبل قبل كم
يوم او قبل كم اسبوع على خطوط السعوديه
يقول حدث على الخطوط السعوديه السفر اذا
جاكرتا ومسار رحله عجيب غريب الرياض جده
جاكرتا ثم تتاخر رحله ساعتين اقلاع وعنده
صعود طائره نتفاجا اننا نذهب الى ماليزيا
ولم يكن ذلك في جدول رحله عند الحجز من
المسؤول عن الازعاج الركاب المسافرين اول
شيء هل تحس يعني
هل يزعجك انه مسؤول عنده تواصل مباشر معك
يبدي من تعارض بشكل عام وثانيا على نفس
الانزعاج هذا اللي يمكن كثير همم يصادفونه
همم فتره
ابدا ما يزعجني بالعكس يعني ما كلفنا
وشرفنا من المقام الكريم بهاء في هالمكان
الا اللي لخدمه الجميع
انا دائما اقول للزملاء في الهيئه احنا
مسؤولين امام الله وامام القياده الله
يحفظها عن 100 مليون عميل
وسيكونون 330 مليون
راحتهم
والتاكد منهم فعلا يطيرون في الوقت
والخدمات تقدم لهم باحسن يعني باعلى مستوى
وانه اذا فيه ازعاج او همم تحديات يواجهون
هذه مسؤوليته
واداره القطاع الجوده وحمايه المسافرين
هذا من اهم ادوار اللي فعلا نحرص على انه
نتعامل مع جميع
تحديات وشكاوي المسافرين الان مع الوزير
الله يحفظها يعني
واجه موقف كلنا نعتذر عنه صراحه
[موسيقى]
اللي حصل هو يعني حصل يعني عطل فني زي ما
تكلمنا على موضوع انه اعطاء الفنيه
لتقل الركاب همم
جده
كانت نازله في في
بانك كوكو حصل لها يعني همم ساحقه
وفي 65 راكب ااا مجموعه من الركاب
المعتمرين يعني مجموعه واحده
ماليزيين ما كان في بالامكان توزيعهم وكان
هم اصروا انهم يطلعون على على رحله واحده
واحده
وللاسف انه الاخوان يعني اللي كانوا
يعملون اللي مسؤولين عن تنسيق الرحلات ترى
انه هذا افضل حل للنحط نركبهم على الرحله
همم جاكرتا ونوقف الرحله في في ماليزيا
يعني بنحل المشكله بنحل المشكله هذا ولي
ولا صاحبي
الا ساعه ايقاف
صباح الخير مقبول
ويخالف الامر
وعلى الاقل تقدير يعني انت المفروض
بحيث انه هو كان فيه ضعف وخلف التواصل وتم
التعامل معه طبعا في اجراءات اتخذتها يعني
اداره
حمايه المسافرين في موضوع التعويض سواء
للمسافرين اللي في جاكرتا او المسافرين
الماليزيين اللي تاخروا وكذلك همم تم يعني
تفاهم مع الاخوان في خطوط السعوديه على
عمليات همم بروتوكولات واجراءات
التعديلات هذه الطريقه هذه انه مخالفه
والتواصل عندهم مع المسافرين والاهم يعني
يعني تاكد اخوي عمر انه هذا المشاكل او
التحديات
تحدث دائما بس كيف نتعامل معها كيف
نعالجها باقل الظهر يعني انت اليوم طالما
عندك طائرات وعندك محركات وعندك حركه
مستمره اتوقع ان يكون عندك بس يجب انه لما
تحدث المشكله اني اتعامل معها من خلال
الاجراء السليم وتعامل
مسار رحله عجيب الرياض جده جاكرتا انا
بديته لاحظ مؤخرا لانه اغلى من الرحلات ما
عاد تطلع من الرياض يعني قبل فتره بروح
عمان روح عمان ما في رحله مباشره الرياض
جده عمان او مسقط فطرت اني اخر خطوط
العمانيه
هل هذه لها دخل بموضوع التموضع حق
السعوديه
المفروض يكون في مرحله انتقاليه وفي تنسيق
يعني حتى قبل اسبوعين كان في اجتماع بين
الجميع الاطراف
لتاكد من انه فيه المرحله الانتقاليه تكون
سلسه ولا تتاثر العمليات او الرحلات الى
ان يتم تشغيل ناقل الوطني الجديد في سؤال
على ما سبب وجود برنامج الربط الجوي تحت
هيئه السياحه وليس تحت الطيران المدني هذا
يقصد فيه وفتح الوجهات الجديده
طبعا البرنامج الرابط الجوي هو من اهم
البرامج اللي نعمل عليها اليوم هو يعني
يقود البرنامج معي الاخ احمد الخطيبه من
وزير السياحه انا اعضه في البرنامج وارسل
لجنه التنفيذيه في البرنامج والعمل بيننا
وبين الاخوان في السياحه وحتى وزاره الحج
والعمره يعني همم دائم وهو همم مركز على
همم دعم مسارات تخدم وتحت السياحه تخدم
سياح تخدم
استقطاب سياح المملكه
من ناحيه الطيران فكيف نستطيع انه همم
نحفز الحركه من هذه المحطات سواء معتمرين
او سياحه فعلا يعني استحدثنا السنه هذه
السنه الماضيه عفوا فيها 22 17 مسار جديد
فيديوهات جديده من خلال هذا البرنامج
وعندنا يعني برامج نتوس هو يصب علاقته في
الطيران في السعوديه الطيران ويصب في نفس
هدف في الطيران اللي هو من المياه اللي
250 بالضبط هذا سؤال يقول المطار جزاء
الجديد هل سيتم اغلاق القديم ومتى تاريخ
افتتاح الجديد وانهاء الاعمال جديد طبعا
يعني احنا برده يعني نعتذر لاهالينا في
الاعزاء في جيزان حبيبه على تاخر مشروع هو
من 2012 بداواجه صعوبات من ناحيه الموقع
والطبيعه التربه والمقاول عموما المطار
الان يعني قطع مراحل صراحه ممتازه ومتجاوز
عربيه في المئه اعتقد كان فيها في برنامج
المشروع برنامج جدا بصراحه همم واطلع في
التلفزيون يعني صور وهمم يعني المشروع وين
وصل يتوقع ان شاء الله انه نهايه 23
همم المطار وهيكون صراحه مطار مميز وبيعمل
نقله نوعيه للخدمات التي تقدم الان المطار
القديم في يعني النقاش
جهات ثواني همم جهه العسكريه وغيرنا او
انه يستخدمات اخرى فيه فيه لازقه الخيارات
متاحه بس المهم هو موضوع انه فعلا نستطيع
بحول الله ان نفتح مطار نهايه هذه السنه
نهايه 23 ومطار ابها يعني كان عندنا
الامير تركي بن طلال لحد الضيوفنا وتكلم
انه ضمن برامج التخسيس همم وشوش اخر بدايه
على مطار ابها كذلك من المطارات اللي
صراحه يعني فيها تحدي كبير يضيق همم السحر
الموجوده فيه اليوم طبعا سوريا ما شاء
الله عليه متابع دقيق وعلى المطار همم
صحيح هو الان المطار ساعه مليون ونص راكب
لحالي همم في 2019 وصل المسافرين اربعه
ونصف تخيل يعني ههه
لو بصير عندك رحلتين همم تتزاعلن ما تجد
مكانها في الصاله
فهو هو هو من المشاريع اللي مطروح على
التخصيص
اييه بس قبل التخصيص الان تمت الموافقه من
خلال اللجنه العليا على انه ااه راسط مبلغ
لي توسعه مؤقته تحسينات داخل مطار لزياره
السعه يمكن حوالي مليون او اقل واكثر على
الاقل الى ان يتم الانتهاء من مشروع تخصيص
التخصيص قطع منتهينا من الدراسات الجدول
الفنيه والاقتصاديه والملاحيه همم حتى ما
يسمى بالماركت ساوند يعني استطلاع اراء
المستثمرين
وسيتم همم الانتهاء من ال- وعملنا مسابقه
على التصميم لانه توجيهات طويل العمر انه
يكون دائما المطارات تاخذ همم هويتها او
يعني تصميمها من هويه المنطقه صح فعملوا
على الكود العمراني في عسير وكل
الاستشاريين المصممين اخذهم الزملاء في
جوله
باشراف الامير تركي
في عسير ونتوقع ان شاء الله انه ينتهي من
تصاميم قريبا ويبدا موضوع المشروع لكن في
اعمال مؤقته تم الموافقه عليها في اللجنه
العليا
برئاسه سيدي على اللي هي تشمل ابها
والطائف
والقصيم و و ينبع
في نفس السياق مطار القنفذه يقول اهل ال
ال المحافظه همم يعني متفاجئين او يعني
مستغربين انه وضع الحجر الاساس من قبل
امير المنطقه في 20 20 المفروض نخلص 23
الى الان ما بدها
صح صحيح
يعني كم اعاده النظر في المطار لانه فيه
اييي
مشروع يغطي جميع بحر الاحمر يعني المشروع
للامانه والبحر الاحمر
وبطلات الامانه والبحر الاحمر وغيرها من
المشاريع اللي على البحر الاحمر
تتقاطع مع هذا المشروع فبالتالي تم يعني
تريث الى ان يتم اعاده همم
البحر الاحمر بالكامل همم في سؤال على
موضوع امن المطار انه في في اشاعات انه
بيسلم لشركه خاصه همم فهل في شركه امنيه
خاصه مؤهله لها مسؤوليه الكبيره الاشعه
صحيحه
طبعا
المطارات دوليه في ثلاثه نماذج
فيها دول
تشرف على امن المطارات بشكل دوله نفسها زي
ما عندنا في المملكه اليوم
وفي دول نموذج هجين اييه دوله تشرف ولكن
مهام معينه يقوم بها الخطا الخاص وفي دول
القطاع الخاص بالكامل يقدم خدمات الامن في
المطارات هذا الموضوع اسف طرح قبل عده
سنوات ومعلومات اللي بقول لك اياها دراسه
العامه
همم
وفي توجه الى انه فعلا يخصص قطاع لانه
فعلا همم كثير الان يعني
المهام في المطارات تكون فيها عده جهات
يعني في القوات الجويه تقدم الحمايه
للمطارات الخارج
الامن الدوله تقوم في الحمايه في داخل
التفتيش وفي داخل المطاعم الداخليه
والجوازات الشرطه المرور جمالك في عده
خدمات امنيه تقدم الجهد متعدده في توجه
الى انه فعلا توحد على الدراسه الوزراء
هيئه الخبراء ونتوقع انه يعني يطلع فيها
توجيه على على خيار معين همم قريبا بحول
الله السؤال على الاجابه على السؤال هل في
شركه نعم في شركات يعني شركات الامنيه في
المملكه الكثيره واخرها شركه سيف اللي هي
شركه تابعه
بيعرفوا عندهم بصراحه ما شاء الله
امكانيات كبيره وقفزوا قفزات نوعيه خلال
الفتره الماضيه حتى احنا نتكلم معهم اليوم
على برفض النظر عن ما ينتج عن هذا الموضوع
على همم اللي هو الخدمات الاطفال في
المطارات خدمات الارتفاع في المطارات هي
خدمات جدا جدا مهمه فيها معدات وموظفين
وهمم
وتستخدم وتكاليف وكانت تقوم بها الهيئه
همم
همم خلال السنوات الماضيه الان تم تحويل
المطارات وجود جهه متخصصه زي شركه سيف قد
يساهم بشكل في تحسين الخدمه ورفع الكفاءه
هذا يسال يقول ليش في اختلاف في السوق
الحره بين الصلاه الداخليه والصلاه
الدوليه هل في اختلاف السوق الحره هو
طبيعه الحال لانه موضوع
يعني اللي داخل المطار هذا ما هي ما هي
همم
اسواق عاديه يعني
الداخليه انت داخل تداخل الاقتصاد
عموما ترى في دراسه يعني كبيره على
الموضوع
على الموضوع
هذا ترى موجود هو العمل المؤقت كان له همم
فقد خدمه المسافرين وقت كاس العالم لان
صراحه
في كذلك طبعا ابعد من ذلك في الان المشروع
لدراسه
يعني فعلا تحسين مستوى الاسواق الحره ليس
فقط المطارات حتى في الموانع جهه اخرى
في مجموعه اسئله من من
الهواتف يعني والممارسين لرياض في الطيران
اييي على موضوع عدم توفر وقود طائرات
صغيره الا في الثمامه ورابط فقط
موضوع الرسوم عاليه جدا هي الاعلى عالميه
على كلامه همم
اللي هي رسوم مناوله الطائرات الصغيره
في رسوم اسعار مواقف الطائرات لتدفعها
الشركات الدوليه
ومتى نرى الطائرات المائيه بالمملكه هذه
خليها بعد شويه بس الاولى موضوع الرسوم
والموضوع يعني ثلاث
اولا الرياضات الطيران الشراعي
والترفيهيه همم فيه دراسه
كريم بعد الحوادث اللي حصلت سنوات
كنت حوادث مؤسس على الحقيقه
فتم توجيه من المقاومه الكريم انه يعاد
دراسه هذا الموضوع بشكل شمولي والتحديات
والاجراءات وفعلا
اتومات الهيئه تقريبا دراسه معياريه
ومتكامله اخذت الاعتبار كثير من الدول
وكيف نماذجها في التعامل مع هذا النوع من
الطيران او الطيران
ونعمل انه يعني يصدر فيها توجيه ان شاء
الله قريبا بحول الله تعالى
طلبات كثيره على انه يوقف صح همم بالنسبه
للطيران الخاص طبعا وهذه سيعالج في موضوع
التكاليف اليوم الموضوع محتكر في عندك
جهتين اللي هي او ثلاث محدوده فتح الشرطه
في الان- كذلك في اجتماع
الاخير فعلا
مبارك وتنفي قراره مجموعه كبيره من
المبادرات في همم
استراتيجيه الطيران الخاص اللي هو همم عرف
الطيران اسمه طيران العام لانه الطيران
العام هو الطيران التجاري انت عندك تجاري
طيران عارض وطيران همم وطيران العام اللي
هو الطائر الخاص اللي تنتهي مجموعه من
القطاعات في استراتيجيه يعني طويل العمر
مره حريص عليها احنا
يعني عندنا تسريب كثير للحركه في ما يخص
موضوع ال ال ابراهيم وكثير من الطائرات
اللي ملاكها سعوديين اليوم مسجله
لانه ما في خدمات كافيه مافيه صيانه جيده
يعني مهاجع ففي الان عملنا دراسه متكامله
وفي تم اعتماد يكون
تقريبا ست مطارات للطيران الخاص قادمه
وتسعه داخل مطارات خائنه
15 مجموعه 15
من القطاع الخاص او من
البيايف
وجزء بالحكومه لتمويل ااا تطوير قطاع خاص
خلال سنوات
لخدمه مشاريع البحر الاحمر
والى فرسان حتى يعني الاخوان في فرسان
الاهالي المواطنين نعمل على انه يكون كان
في فكره مطاعم كنت ما سالت عنها انه في
مطار فرسان يعني ما كان في وقتها رؤيا
واقتصادي
الموضوع المهابط المائيه والطائرات
المائيه وسي بليز ممكن تعالج هذا
البحر الاحمر بس احنا يعني داعمين في هذا
الموضوع ان شاء الله ممكن نشوفها بحول
الله خلال سنوات القادمه
في الاكل في الطائرات هل تلزمون المشغلين
بهذا الشيء يعني بالعكس
يسالون همم بعض همم
المضيفه اذا انت عندك حساسيه منهم معين بس
مش دائما بس موجود همم كارت اعتقد انه
ملاحظه الجزيره
في في همم جوده
وحمايه المسافرين ويبلغون فيها هل هناك
توجه لتعديل الانظمه الداخليه الهيئه حيث
انه يصعب جدا وصول لموظفي الهيئه لحل
المشكله ودائما هناك همم انظمه معقده لرفع
الشكوى او الاستفسار او التواصل
يعني في صراحه هذه اكثر من نقطه جاءت انه
الاتمته لنظام الهيئه غير مكتمل لا يوجد
بمكانيات طلب رخص همم او تجديدها لا يمكن
الفوتره الا بالحضور الشخصي لا يوجد ارشفه
الهيئه يمكن تجديد او كمال اي طلب عن
طريقها ففي كثير ملاحظات على الموضوع
الاتمته الخدمات يعني هذه ملاحظه في محلها
100% انا اول ما يعني
في الهيئه وبعد شهر كده كان عندي من اهم
الاهداف اللي حطيتها على راس الخيمه
وموضوع
يعني ممكن
يعني همم
متضايق جدا انه كيف الهيئه اللي هي من اهم
الهيئات واقطع حساس جدا ومعايير والسلامه
فيها يعني
متخلفين
صح تعبير مقارنه بما وصلتنا الدوله
المملكه في
حول رقمي ممكن جزء بسيط في جهه اخرى واعرف
الامثله اللي سواء يعني طبعا الفلاك شيف
عندنا واللي هو الراب شير وبعدين همم نظام
همم
ناجز في العادل يعني ما كان يتخيل اليوم
التقدم واللي وصلنا فيه في النظام العدلي
وكيف انه الان احكام وكالات جلسات
تملك قبل ابناء نتمنى قبل الفتره هو يعمل
في السفاره في القدس
الرقميه او الحكومه الالكترونيه المملكه
اليوم سباقه فيها بشكل كبير الحقيقيه فمن
غير المغبور والمرض اللي احنا نكون في
الهيئه ولذلك بدانا في مبادره همم مشروع
ضخم اللي هو التحول الرقمي في الحقيقه
وهو يعني احد اسباب معالجه كثير من
المشاكل اللي تكلم عليها في الاول يعني
الملاحه الجويه نربط مع المطرات نربط مع
وزاره الحج ضربه مع الجوازات ضربه معلم
الخارجيه احنا عملنا اليوم متداخل مع في
هذا الجهاز تصاريح امنيه تصاريح الطائرات
تصاريح الدبلوماسيين همم تصريح الطائرات
بشكل عام مواسم الحج وكيف الرابط اللي
تاكد انه يعني في تداخل كبير جدا من غير
المقبول ان احنا نكون اليوم همم بهذا
الصوره فانا اتفق معاها
واكد لكم منها من اولوياتنا وعندنا الان
بدانا يعني تاخر المشروع دخلنا فيه يعني
اشكالات معينه لكن الان بدانا في اطلاق
مشروع التحول الرقمي الهيئه دي طبعا هياخذ
حوالي سنتين بس ان شاء الله انه الجميع
يعني همم يعني يلاحظ تغيير همم
هذا يسال يقول هل وضع معاليه او احد من
اقاربه قبل تعيين رئيس غرام في موقف محرج
كمسافر كثير مش اكثر موقفه لها بالعكس
يعني شوف انا
يمكنني اقول لك مثال بصراحه انا يعني في
التسعينات والثمانينات لما بدات الحياه
العمليه كانت في حسابك وكنت اسافر كل ربع
سنه للشرق الخاص كنت مسؤول عن التسويق
لاحد المنتجات
كنت دائما كل ربع رويال الكوريه الى
اليابان
فاوقف في استراليا
كان فيه شعار لما اطلع من باب الطياره بس
هذا الكلام عام 89
لا زال راسك في ذهني ولازم اعمل اليوم اني
احقق ان شاء الله يقول للشعار انه نظما
انك انت فتح باب الطياره الى تغادر باب
المطار دقيقه
واو
تقول لي تتحلم يمكن بس انا صراحه هذا
الهدف اللي انا اسال يومي لتحقيقه
المواقف المحرجه كثيره يعني بتصل يعني في
المطار تجد والله يا فقد
انت مستعجل وتجد و الله ان الرحله نص ساعه
يعني وصلت بدري في عقبه قالوا كده وقف في
الساحه البوابه غير جاهزه يعني في حالات
كثيره نتعامل معهم بدون شك ترى كثير
مشاركانه في المطارات تقدموا لنا اليوم
عشان نكون واقعيين ونقدم لهم بصراحه
الجوازات اليوم احد الامثله الناجحه اللي
فعلا عملوا نقله نوعيه في المطارات يعني
اليوم جوازات انا اذكر من الزمنات كنا
نجيء بحكم الحنه السعودي ندخل معهم مره
المواطنين والخليجيين ما ناخذ دقائق لكن
نشوف كيف السروات ونحزن لهم ما شاء الله
ما في احد عنده جوازات حتى عندنا بعض
الزملاء يقولون يا جماعه هدوء الراكب اول
ما فتح الباب
وصلت فيعني الجوال في الجوازات الجمله في
الجمارك الحقيقه الدوار اللي يقومون فيها
الحقيقه دوار مهمه وساهمتك في تحسين تجربه
ابو سعد باقي تدور علينا كمل بقيه الحلقات
وله فعلا يعني نكمل هذا الدور وان المسافر
يشعر بالراحه
والاستمتاع حقيقه من يدخل المطار الى
يغادر المطار ولو بختم هالحوار ابو عبد
الله يقول لك
عندنا هدف كبير 330 مليون مسافر 250 وجهها
وعده مستدفات ضمن الاستراتيجيه وايش اكبر
تحدي همم يواجهك او يهدد قدرتنا على تحقيق
الاهداف
والله اشوف يعني عشان نكون واقعيين
القياده الله يحفظها الدوله كلهم مؤكلات
اللي نحتاجها اليوم موجوده
تحدي الاكبر يمكن هو عدم التنسيق الكافي
بين الاطراف انا ارجع واقول دائما التنسيق
والتنسيق والتنسيق والتواصل ترى ممكن حتى
دائما زملائي وزميلاتي في العمل ملهم مثل
ما رد عليهم قصه المكيجنا والتواصل لانه
80% من المشاكل هي ممكن حلها من خلال
التواصل الامثل هذه كلنا اعمل بنفس الهدف
وانت عندك نفس الهدف لكن تتكلم بلغه
مختلفه هو انه ما في وضوح كيف نستطيع ان
النوائم بين جميع همم اللاعبين واطراف
المدني او الطيران المدني سواء من طيران
او من مطارات او المقدمه خدمات او مجهات
امنيه او حكوميه اخرى او هذا التحدي
الاساسي اذا استطعنا ان نجد توليف
المناسبه بحول الله الهدف قبل الموعد باذن
الله موفقين في تحقيق 330 مليون مسافر
وخدمتهم بشكل ممتاز حتى نكون والله محور
ربطه القارات شكرا لك ابو عبد الله على
اول الدار
تسلم الله يحفظك شكرا لكم شكرا الفهد
القصير في اعداد الحلقه ياسر الغانم وياسر
كردشي خلف الكاميرات وفي التحرير محمد
الديني وفي الهندسه الصوتيه محمد الحسن
وفي الاشراف على الانتاج رزان هيثم هذا
فودكاست سقراط احد منتجات شركه ثمانيه
للنشر والتوزيع
[موسيقى]